Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah
Howdy!
Howdy, howdy, howdy!
Hello!
Congrats on 300k.
Thank you!
Hello Minky!
Hello!
Minky!
What do you mean wrong hat?
This is Indiana Jones.
Thank you for the congratulations!
Thank you!
Happy National Short Girl Appreciation Day.
We appreciate you.
And you are... I'm just kidding.
Cute little ghost self.
I'm average size.
Why is it National Short Girl Appreciation Day?
Oh my god.
I just got home actually because I went out shopping for some Christmas presents for my mom.
And...
I went to this one place and I was like looking and it's like a...
How do you say?
Like locally made things or... Not locally.
Like a... How do you say it?
Like trinkets and things like that.
I don't know.
They might be locally made.
I have no idea.
But I went...
Flea market?
Farmer market?
Maybe.
I was like I'll look and see if they have any cute... My mom likes little trinkets.
Artisan.
Yeah!
I went in and there was a towel that had gnomes on it.
I like pointed at it and went...
Gnomes.
And the owner of the store...
The owner of the store...
I didn't know she was around and she saw me and she was like...
You like gnomes?
I got plenty of gnomes.
I was like...
I feel like the thumbnail misled me.
No!
That's why I censored them!
I censored Matara and Doki because they are not in the stream.
That's why I censored them.
You got misled on your own terms.
But yeah, she was like I got a lot of Christmas gnomes.
And I was like...
I'm gonna go now.
Minky, minky, minky, minky, minky!
Thank you!
Thanks SakiSoho!
Congrats on 300k minky!
So proud of you.
Thank you!
Minky, minky, minky, minky!
Thank you Cajow, welcome back for eight months!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you guys for the 8 months.
Florian, thank you for the 9 months.
Hashtag free the Mataras Matas.
No!
It's all focus on Minky.
No focus on Matara.
Ever.
All Mintos, no Matara.
This is Mint channel.
Mid Mint channel.
Sisa, thanks for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Thanks for the congratulations.
Yippee!
Thank you.
Matara, you sussy Ohio.
Exactly.
I'm focus on her momo.
Shut up!
You are at the...
You are at the wrong place!
Do you have a favorite flower, Minky?
Favorite flower is...
Hydrangea.
Ojisai.
You didn't notice the sensors?
Yeah, they just...
Matara and Doki just fade into obscurity.
It's fine.
Mintos all over.
Okay, Stuart, thank you, but please stop spamming or I have to time you out.
I heard Matara and came running.
Oh, hi there.
I also wanted to say...
I was supposed to do Devil May Cry 3 today.
But I didn't get a lot of sleep.
And then I knew that I was going to have to go and run a bunch of errands before stream.
I literally just got home like 10 minutes ago.
Oh, wait, it's 10 minutes into the stream now.
20 minutes ago.
And I was like, I wanna be, you know...
Full focus for Devil May Cry since it's such an intensive gaming experience.
So...
I was just like, well, you know, I was trying to finish up Indiana Jones anyway.
And this is a game...
Like, last time I played it, the other day, I was like, oh my gosh, it's been 5 hours.
I could go another 5 hours.
Kind of dealio, so I was like...
I'm gonna... I could maybe...
If I just play as much as I want today, I might be able to beat it.
Who knows?
So...
You're the boss.
I appreciate you guys being so patient with me.
But of course there will be...
So I was gonna have Indiana Jones on Monday.
So I just changed the...
The...
The Devil May Cry to Monday instead.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
Indeed.
Indiana Jones games have come a far way since Raiders of the Lost Ark for the Atari...
What?
For the Atari?
I've never played any other...
Any other Indiana Jones games.
Angry car trains.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Hi 300k Minto.
Hello.
Always Jushimatsu.
Profile picture of Hazinger.
Who was sub number 300k?
Who knows?
Maybe the sub number 300k was you.
Was it you Rainy?
Rainy is like, I'm asking but actually...
It was me.
It might have been me.
It was you.
It was me.
It was all me and my 300k accounts.
I know right now I'm typing at the speed of light as all of you guys.
I'm cosplaying as a successful streamer.
Maybe.
I'm cosplaying as someone who...
A streamer who has people watching them.
It's me in the chat.
All me in the chat.
Thank you for the 50 gifts.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We're fine.
That was weird.
Thank you for the gift.
Everything is ok.
I am Minto and so is my wife.
Our wife?
Are we sharing wives?
We share everything.
We share secrets.
What's your secret?
Just pretend I'm your journal.
Actually, don't do that.
Actually, wait a second.
How many Indiana Jones games have there been?
Hi, Doomguy.
It's been a while.
Hi, I am new.
Hello.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank you, Ryan, for the superchat.
Minto saw... Dear Mint, I saw a cute girl at the store.
What do I do?
Run back straight to...
Made Mint channel.
And don't forget who you're loyal to.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifts.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Dear journal, Minto is extra cute today.
I feel blessed.
My magic.
Dear diary, today I got home and opened up the Minto stream.
You're doing it!
You're doing it correctly!
You're doing it correctly.
I'm loyal to the mission, boss.
I'm saluting.
You just can't see.
My hands are up.
Anyway.
Last time we... Indeed.
For some reason, I don't know.
I try... Or rather...
Back up.
Sorry.
My brain moves at a speed.
I tried changing, going into the options.
Changing video stuff.
But I think because it's Xbox.
There's no way to improve graphics.
So maybe... But also, today I feel like it looks a little funky.
I don't know.
There's like something about the textures.
I booted it up and I was like, what?
It looks strange.
Console has less options than PC.
Yeah, I didn't even think about it.
I was just like, oh yeah, because I transferred everything from PC to console.
So, since I originally played this on the PC and then I made my computer go...
Thank you!
Happy.
Happy that you're happy here!
Thank you!
V-dog.
Can't believe I fought...
Oh.
I can't believe I fought me Psycho Mantis for your Christmas presents.
So you like gnomes?
I don't like gnomes.
I just thought it was funny seeing a gnome on a towel.
And then the lady was like, you like gnomes?
There's a bit of a dirt on my monitor screen.
Right where your face is and it looks like a booger is hanging out your nose.
Clean your screen?
Like, don't blame me.
Don't be like, haha Minto, looks like you have a booger hanging from your nose.
Maybe you should have your monitor cleaned?
Gonna miss you, won't be here until next year.
Oh my gosh, no.
Nan, I'll see you next year!
Dear diary, I just recovered from the flu.
Then Minto streamed early.
Is this my reward for trying best to recover?
Yeah!
Aw, Yog, feel better!
She got a dirty nose like a two year old.
God, yeah.
Yeah, I got, I just, you know...
I get everything all over my face.
I eat, and there's just like...
What's like a messy food?
Pudding.
I eat pudding and it's just...
Slobber, like pudding all around my lips.
Spaghetti, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got spaghetti underneath my fingernails from picking it up with my hands.
Just, just that's, you know...
I got spaghetti up my nose.
Spaghetti everywhere.
What?
Yeah.
Last time we played Indiana Jones.
We...
They mentioned the great circle.
Oh my god, that person.
There was a lady in the background.
And her arms were kind of glitching around.
It looked like she was doing the...
Wait, they don't love me like I do.
Wait, they don't love you like I do.
It looks like she was doing that dance.
I don't promise, but we'll return if there's Ace Combat 8.
Okay.
That's not on me though.
Congrats on 300k.
Thank you!
But yeah, so...
And then we also discovered right after I ended was that...
They were tracking my dad or Indy's dad.
They were tracking Indiana Jones.
Like, they've been...
They've been watching him.
They've been watching him sleep.
They've been collecting his hair.
Putting it in jars.
They've been collecting his...
His pant pocket lint and everything.
They're obsessed with him.
Dear Diary, there's been a lot of stuff to do at work.
However, Mintos started streaming and my day became better.
Here in the office.
So is Snake!
No!
Snakes don't belong in offices.
Have a good day at work!
Oh my god, those twins over there almost kissed.
That was kind of crazy.
But if we continue onward...
Welcome back.
I also noticed, if anybody has motion sick stuff...
I noticed that motion blur was turned on last time.
I'm so sorry.
I thought it was turned off.
What am I wearing?
I am...
I am a normal guy.
So yeah, I'm really sorry.
I know that this game can be tough for some people because of it being first person.
And I think I look around a little erratically, so...
I apologize.
I'm wearing...
Alright, so...
Yeah, we discovered that they were stalking us and we saw a cat and we saw a dog and it was very cute.
I liked that part.
Hey man.
This is my best buddy right here.
Yup.
We are pals, aren't we?
Who are you staring at like that?
Oh, me?
Oh, he's scratching his butt.
That's my minky.
Who's this smelly guy?
This is...
This is Bradley.
Bradley is like the best...
Oh, he's talking to us.
What we're...
Sorry.
Bless you, Bradley.
He's our best friend.
What are you talking about?
He went, who is we?
Nah, everybody at the camp knows us.
Everyone around here knows...
Bradley and Indy.
The double...
The double guys.
Oh, bless you.
Gosh.
He's smiling at me.
Oh, hello.
You okay?
Why are you so frustrated about?
He's kissing me.
Bradley.
I didn't know you wanted to take our relationship that far.
I don't think I'm ready.
I need time to think about this.
Bless you.
That was a lot of words just for saying hi.
You're sick now.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna catch whatever they have.
I see Joaquin like he pooped his pants.
He actually might have.
He actually might have pooped his pants.
Friendship ended with Bradley.
I think he's checking me out.
Hi.
Why do they become so...
Why do they like look at you like that when you stare at them for so...
When you look at them they become like so soft.
What happened?
Oh my god.
What snack do you think I should...
Oh my gosh, Broca!
It's been forever.
What snack should I get?
Fruit gummies.
Cap'n Crunch.
Persimmons.
Brie.
Ice cream.
Popcorn.
Popcorn!
Mix the popcorn and the Cap'n Crunch.
It's the salty and sweet.
Josh Boy, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Kurochina, happy birthday!
May I request one happy birthday song from Lee Minto?
Of course you can!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Kurochina.
Happy birthday!
Alright, enough clowning around, guys.
So, let's see.
Last time I had also finished all the fieldwork.
We had some discoveries like the underground boxing ring.
Whatever this riddle of the ancients is.
These discoveries, these are the ones that I don't plan on completing all of them.
You know, to 100% the game or anything like that.
It's all good.
We have some lost artifacts we haven't gotten.
Wow, we're only missing 5 medicine bottles.
That's pretty good.
Guys, I'm late.
What have you missed?
You missed...
You missed us getting 2 boyfriends.
You missed us getting 2...
Watch, watch, watch this.
GF skill, watch this, watch this.
Watch him become so soft for us.
He's just melting looking at us.
Look.
Are you whistling?
How is that coming out of your mouth?
Ok, maybe...
Ok, nevermind.
Maybe it was only the first time.
Ok.
This bro's hair thinning.
Don't be mean to him.
He just...
Hello.
He just needs, you know...
The Riz is fading away.
Maybe we were like a novelty at first.
And now he's seen us again and he's like, you know what, actually...
Ah...
Oh.
Pirate, I just saw your thing.
Since you have a capture card and are streaming from a different device anyway, couldn't you just use your laptop for VTube Studio and OBS and play the game from your main PC?
Technically, I guess.
But...
My laptop doesn't handle other stuff well either.
I don't know.
I don't really have a place to put other things.
My maid cafe where I stream is quite small.
All things considered.
That's also my fault.
I buy a lot of trinkets.
So, now we're going to go investigate the fountain.
And, I think, move on to another area.
No!
Bradley, you're hungry!
He's hungry.
Someone feed him.
Oh my god, it looks like a ghost in there.
It's kind of freaky.
Oh shoot.
I was like, what just happened?
We almost got caught.
But we didn't.
We're too good.
This way?
Up this way.
This guy might catch us though.
I'm scared of him.
I'm just walking.
Oh my god.
Okay, he didn't notice.
We're okay.
He didn't notice.
Nice.
Over here.
Over here?
While I was in Atlanta, a wisp sneezed and someone Tascaru'd them in real life.
I love VTubers.
Yeah, you guys...
I feel like becoming a VTuber fan kind of alters your everything.
Fountain of Confession.
Gotta turn it up a little bit.
Oh yeah, that's right.
We went to a place and like...
And we saw like the grave and everything.
Oh wait, so what's it?
Investigate the fountain and use the camera for hints.
Okay, let's see what this says.
Oh, tit.
Nice.
Okay.
What else we got?
Morten, thank you so much for the 10 Gibson!
She is not interested in your story at all.
I think they might hate each other.
Let's see.
This is such a cool fountain if it worked.
Like it's so...
Look at his little paw.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, can we go in here?
Requires fountain gate key.
They are gate keying us.
Do I need to eat?
Is anyone watching?
Well, isn't that just handy dandy?
Finally finished the indie movie VOD on the topic of indie games.
I wish they finished making the one that would have used the forced unleashed engine.
What one would that have been?
Chomp.
Chomp?
How do I eat this again?
Wait, how do I eat it again?
I can't remember.
Wait.
Oh, is it because I'm full?
Oh, I forgot that the fruit is for the stamina.
And... what's this?
Open that.
It's red.
Maybe with the...
It looks like it can be opened, right?
Hmm...
I don't think it works.
Denied.
Do I have to get the lock specifically?
I don't think so.
Why does it turn red though?
Like I can hit it, you know?
The hitbox is finicky?
Okay.
Come on!
If I crouch, it makes me stand up.
I don't think I'm hitting it.
I think I need to like... okay, okay, hold on.
No.
Use the rake?
Let's try the rake instead.
Oh my God.
So much money in here.
Holy moly!
Wait, why is there silly music?
Is it because I stole?
Nobody saw me.
Nobody saw me!
Open up, baby.
Oh, I put on my Indiana Jones outfit.
Okay.
I guess we don't want to be a guy.
Sure.
We don't want to be a...
Okay, that works.
Sure.
I put on my other outfit too.
The Temple of Doom outfit.
I realized I didn't have it on last stream either.
Wait, but my...
Okay, I guess we'll come back for it.
Hello?
Oh, here we go.
I'm climbing, I'm climbing, I'm climbing.
And swing.
Swing!
That works.
Where do you want me to go?
Maybe here.
Climb out.
No one can see me.
Okay, perfect.
So this guy...
No.
This guy...
That guy...
What?
Wait.
Oh, are we...
I guess I'm going to the other side.
I hope no one notices.
Do I not need to take a picture of that?
The confessions?
And push.
He needs to see the darkness.
Darkness.
Yeah, I just snapped his ankle.
Nice.
Did someone say the door to darkness?
What was the clue again?
Indy.
Indy, can you stop doing that?
This is...
This is his...
Sisyphus.
Hold on.
I can't undo this.
Oh, here we go.
Alright.
What's the clue?
Notes.
I think that was my birthday today.
Happy birthday, Mike!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Mike.
App.
So someone said it in chat.
Someone said, light dragon must see the dark, shadow creature must see the light.
So this guy, he's kind of...
Well, he is...
He is...
He is in the light?
Shadow?
I mean, doesn't it depend on the day?
The time of day?
Okay, so you look at...
You look at the sun.
But that's exactly what he was doing before.
What's the point?
Okay.
We'll leave you to it.
Gosh, I'm so glad nobody notices this.
Some guys swinging from the rafters.
Where's your foot, buddy?
Where's your foot?
Is it down here?
Do you guys see a foot?
No one ever looks up.
It's true.
Gamers never look up.
Do you guys see a foot?
Maybe...
We grab the dragon claw.
Oh my God!
Oh my God, I didn't recognize Gina.
He has a concussion now.
Gina...
Is this a hidden door, Dr. Jones?
Where's my hat?
Are you pursuing some forbidden secret, perhaps?
Look, Gina.
This has been swell.
And I hope you find your sister, but...
I work best on my own.
Where's my hat?
He's here.
He's so distraught without it.
I'm working on it.
Oh my God, what's wrong with his armpit?
Yeah, I did.
A claw.
Can I climb from here?
I can.
What was the point of me going through all of this anyway?
Item limit has been reached.
If I could just get up from here, why did I go inside?
She doesn't care about me.
She's not even looking.
Where is she going?
Gina, what are you doing?
Gumdrop, welcome to Mambu Shop.
I believe you are the true GW.
How can we be sure you are not part of the selection for societal sanity?
That you are not a daughter of the Patriots.
You just have to trust me, bro.
Alright.
Okay, so that guy looks at the sun and you look behind.
You look in the shadows.
Maybe they look at each other?
I have to go all the way around.
I don't feel like the sun should have a play because the sun can be in different directions depending on the time of day, right?
Like it would be kind of silly if it were that...
Oh.
Well, now we are in here.
So cool.
Why is the music all spooky?
I'm scared.
It's okay.
We'll just grab this here.
Wait.
This bandage.
Oh there it is.
It just took a minute.
Alright.
So you...look.
Look, he's looking at us.
Are you obsessed with us or something, other dragon?
Are you obsessed with this dragon?
Do you want to look at him all the time?
No, no, no.
Keep going.
No, Indy don't pull it back.
Oh, now I learned he can pull it back.
And then we pull.
We don't want our knees to break again so we'll go this way.
And down.
Nice.
Yikes!
I can see that Dina!
I hope no one heard...
I hope no one heard that.
Wow, what an ugly baby.
Dina!
Wow, the fountain.
Fountain gate.
What else is in here?
Oh, is this a puzzle?
Puzzle?
Oh, ok.
Lord Farquaad.
Shut up!
I'm exploring!
I don't even know what you're talking about yet.
Ok, don't go back there.
Oh, that was the other dragon.
That's right.
Oh, and then...
Oh my goodness.
This is quite the contraption.
This looks like something I need to pull.
I need to yank that.
You're really yanking my chain.
Prime backseater out.
Shut up.
She really is just a backseater, isn't she?
What handles is she talking about?
What handles are... Handles?
What is she talking about?
Them love handles?
Paw?
I don't know what she's talking about.
What handles?
Look up?
No?
It said the handles appeared when the fountain turned.
Handles.
In front of her?
This guy.
Someone's talking.
Ok, it's turning again.
Nice jump.
She's got such skill.
Why does the game feel a little bit more goofy today?
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Why does it feel like super goofy today?
I don't...
She doesn't care.
The baptism.
Baptism.
I got an achievement for my baptism?
Oh shutterbug.
Captured 50 photographs.
Nice.
What's this now?
Go away!
Game pass.
X
What is she doing?
Gina?
Gina, what are you doing girl?
Alright, what do you do here?
Ew, it looks like hair.
Oh, he's gonna baptize the guy!
Right?
You give him the water and then he goes...
Ok, hold on.
I think we need to redo it.
Ok.
Nasty sludge water that hasn't been touched in like a bajillion years.
Ok, keep going.
Alright, nice.
Baptize.
Baptized.
Ok,
now we probably have to do the other side.
Wow.
They even put him away.
Let's do the other side.
Alright, come here Gina.
Oh, I believe my cat mummy might be in there.
If it's in there, how did the other person get in there?
Did they do all of this?
And then lock it up again?
There she goes.
She's such a go-getter.
She looks like she's about to fall asleep.
That doesn't look like baby Moses.
Ok, what does baby Moses look like, huh?
Huh?
Tell you.
Did you know him personally?
I don't think so.
No.
I'm rando-nodding here, ok?
Gosh.
Ok.
So we need to like...
turn this all...
so that he can get through.
Oh, those are wood planks.
Oh, I forgot to take a picture!
Whoops, sorry.
I tampered with the evidence.
Before I took a picture.
Get out of the picture, Gina!
Is that what that means?
I don't know what I'm supposed to do with the wood.
Is there another rotator?
Or is it just this?
Why is it sometimes the big wheel and sometimes the small wheel?
I can...
Wait!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so close.
Wait, I almost did it.
I think?
Yeah, there's just that wood right there.
Oh my god.
Ok, ok, ok.
See, like this.
Ok.
Keep going.
Did I do it or is that... Oh, that wood is still there.
Ok, hold on.
Just kidding!
Indy, you need to commit, ok?
How do I get this...
Edged?
No!
Alright, now go up.
Go up.
And get it here.
Yeah!
Alright, now sideways.
Now big, big, big circle.
Big circle time.
Yeah!
Oh wait!
Oh, it's still there.
Oh.
The great circle.
3, 2, 1, woo!
Or boo!
Yeah, boo!
Thank you!
The great circle.
We found the great circle.
How do I get it away?
Hey!
It's stuck in there.
I thought I was a genius and I figured out the puzzle.
Upside down T on the middle.
Let's see what happens.
Wait, what does this one do?
Oh,
can I just pick either one?
One sends him forward and one sends him back.
Wait, so can I make him go through?
Happy National Short Girl Day Mint Yugo Short Queen.
Thanks.
Alright, alright, alright.
Wait.
Now?
I don't think that's where...
Wait.
Oh, no.
Ok, I'm going to send him through.
I'm going to send him through.
Right?
There he goes.
And then he gets stuck.
Yeah, yeah.
And then he's going to go whoopie doo, flippy flip.
Just kidding.
I can't move it while he's in there.
Or maybe, let me try the other layers.
Ok, nevermind.
Just kidding.
I think you had it at first but messed it up.
That might have been the case because I didn't know what I was doing.
I had it?
Wait, what do you mean I had it?
How did I have it?
Wait, hold on.
If I spin it once more...
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Big spin.
If I do a big spin once more...
This one.
Do I have to do them all?
I thought I've been able to do them...
Hmm?
Oh, that's why...
Oh, that's why it would sometimes spin all together.
Ok, ok, ok, ok.
I was like, why?
Isn't it supposed to all spin together?
What?
Ok,
ok, ok.
Wait, stop, stop, stop.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
Go back, go back, go back.
Wait, actually, no.
Wait, I need it.
I need it in that one over there.
Ok, hold on.
I have to re-spin it around.
I'm trying!
Wait, how am I supposed to...
Ok, hold on.
I know where it needs to go!
Oh my god!
My brain!
This is like the damn slide puzzles!
Ok, hold on.
How do I get it to...
Do outside first.
What do you mean do outside first?
I'm trying to do any bit.
Don't say bit!
I'm confused!
I'm confused.
Move the ship now.
No, I can't.
I have to move the ship.
Here, I'll prove it to you.
Unless it works.
That would be kind of cool.
But I think the ship has to go all the way to the end.
See?
I can't move it now.
Oh, whoops.
See?
I can't move it.
You have to have it all go in one turn.
I thought the ship pushed the wood.
No.
Ok, hold on.
So upside down T.
T.
Hold on.
I'm getting lost in the saws.
Wait.
Ok, hold on.
I'm just looking.
No, no, no.
Up in the...
I did it!
There he goes all the way!
First try!
I'll go with you.
Oh yeah, we did it.
There he goes.
There we go.
It won't let me punch her.
It won't let me punch her if I get too close.
Alright, now I push the baby.
Push the baby!
Yippee!
First try!
Push the baby.
Nice!
There we go.
Nice.
Why are these lit?
Gina, Gina, I have concerns.
Gina, I...
Gina, I have concerns.
She's gonna touch something.
Why are these lit?
Voss.
Emmerich.
Wow, look at the fire down there.
That's kind of awesome.
Emmerich balls.
Alright, finally.
Anyway.
Oh, I guess it's safe to walk on this.
Fountain underground map.
Ok, here we go.
Pull the lever!
Watch out!
Gina!
Gina, watch out please!
Oh my God.
Whoops, sorry.
That's what she almost just did.
Oh no, our fortune and glory.
Oh, she's getting a little sauna bath.
Ok.
Look at her little sauna and everything.
Careful, Gina.
Does this look like there's a trap that's about to happen?
Does any of these floors look like...
If you step on them wrong, they'll activate something.
We're going carefully.
I don't want to perish in flames.
What do you mean what am I doing?
Well, what is she going to do?
Ok.
Can I take that?
No.
It's getting mighty dark.
Chamber of tribulations?
Oh my God.
What is this?
It looks a little...
Oh no, there's more platforming, you guys.
I hate to say this, but...
What is this?
Who made all of this?
How do I get up there?
Gina, can you give me a hand?
Also the water... Oh, just kidding.
The water is really gross.
Oh wow, that's such a cool effect.
Wow, it's like real oil.
When you walk through it.
Oh wow, it's...
Oh, that's gross.
Oh, but it's so...
That's such a cool touch.
It's also probably flammable.
Yeah, I guess so.
I'm trying to figure out how to get up.
Can you give me a hand, Gina?
Oh, I figured it out.
This seems like some kind of test.
Oh, that one got stuck, so it's okay.
This seems very...
Um, wow.
What, so I just jump through?
Oh god.
Is this supposed to be broken?
Oh my god.
Moment of respect for the poor engineer under NDA in the Vatican whose job is to maintain all the swinging saws.
That's what I'm saying.
Why is that one stuck?
I mean, I'm not gonna complain, but...
I'm okay.
Gina, when are you gonna try, huh?
Okay, you don't run and jump, guys.
You won't... It's overkill, apparently.
I tried running and jumping.
Apparently that's overkill.
Jump!
You think I can make it there?
Or do you think I have to go through here?
I can't tell.
Jump for the beef.
No go right?
Okay.
Oh, I made it.
Oh my god, she's trying.
What?
She's like, haha, idiot, you went the hard way.
Wait, what?
Gina, get out of my way.
I'm trying!
Gina, are you okay?
Did you get clipped?
Uh oh, I think she's about to die.
Alright, your turn.
She shimmied her way over here.
Where were the flames part of that?
Wow, that door!
Wow, we have a lot of points.
I just noticed.
Maybe we should buy some stuff.
We have all this.
Fitness.
Climbing Ace.
You know what?
I'll grab it.
Uh, enemy, or Indy can clinch enemies for longer.
I don't really use, I don't really do that.
Fruit bag!
Unlock.
We need more fruit.
Combat was, oh.
Thanks bookworm.
Ten abilities from adventure books.
Last hit before you provided, uh, yeah.
Exploration.
That's good for now, I think.
Wow, this looks...
Do you think we're gonna fight a dragon?
There's a door?
Question mark?
Maybe not.
This looks kind of well maintained, all things considered.
I'm looking at it.
This craziness.
This looks like that one famous gate.
It's a nice gate.
That one gate.
Yeah.
That one door.
Looks like a door.
Nothing around, nothing here to explore either.
No bread?
No leftover giant bread?
Oh, what's this?
Alright.
Creepy!
What am I taking a picture of?
You?
Oh!
Courtyard plaque.
How could you read that from all the way over here?
Complete the challenges.
That's all it says.
What kind of challenges are we talking about, Dr. Jones?
OK, so this is when you do the molten and make the key.
And then what's in here?
Another room?
OK.
Fascinating.
And these guys...
Their masks are so scary!
They look like they're supposed to be holding something.
Lava, death traps, guardian statues, ominous door, all under the Vatican?
You are actually trying to break into hell?
Maybe.
Alright.
Time to pull!
Hello?
Dr.
Jones.
I missed short round.
Oh god, the game just saved.
There's an awful lot of dead guys in here.
That's a great question.
Oh my god, look how red it is.
Red means scary guys.
What is this?
What does it say?
Wait, what?
Wait, can you hear it?
What did it say?
It's Latin for with.
I know it's a real word.
Isn't that a sorority or fraternity thing, right?
Oh my god!
Ok Gina, I'm trying to be careful around these parts, but you're just literally running through.
That's fine.
The music is so ominous.
It's kind of awesome.
It's a little... It's the gnome.
It's the gnome.
Wait, there's like some...
Oh, what's this?
Big line, short line, three dot line, three dot line.
Horizontal line.
Ok, dead man.
Is this loss?
Might be.
What's this?
Stone tablet.
Maybe.
What do I do with... Ok, let's take this back to over here.
To you.
Oh!
I'm trapped here!
I will?
Oh my god.
Ok.
Do I have to... Oh my god.
I'm thinking!
Ok, I'm gonna run.
I'm just gonna run for it.
I grabbed another...
Ok.
Good thing she's here.
Ok, ok, ok.
Good, good, good.
Nevermind.
Not good, good, good, good, good.
Not good, good, good.
Run Indy, run!
Oh my god.
I almost died, Gina.
Gina, it's getting real hot in here, Gina.
Can I use this one?
Yeah, you think?
Gimme,
gimme, gimme.
Thank you.
Gimme.
And in.
And goodbye fire.
Oh no!
Oh!
Bigger fire!
Wait, bigger fire!
Ok!
Go, go, go!
Fire
will disappear.
Oh my goodness.
I'm in again!
Thank you so much for the Akasupa!
I got robbed on my birthday?
I missed your stream that day.
Wait, not literally robbed.
Just dropping in to say thank you for being you and Mary Kremis.
Not actually robbed.
Cinderathalos, thanks for the 10 gifted.
I hope you're ok.
If you got robbed, don't send me a superchat.
Especially not an Akasupa.
But of course we'll give you a happy birthday song!
Happy birthday to you!
I hope you're ok!
I wish you a merry birthday!
Actually, but it's fine now.
Happy birthday, birthday kid!
What do you mean it's fine now?
It happened at all so it's not fine at all.
Is this the thing blacksmiths work in?
I don't know what we're...
Indy, you are really strong buddy!
Holy moly!
Ok Gina, watch out, ok?
Trying to push me into the fires.
This is so cool!
This place rules, right?
This is so awesome!
Ok, next trial.
Look at that!
We made the first key!
I saw!
Do
I do this?
What is she trying to say?
Yes?
What do you mean yes?
Vatican in 1937.
Secret underground death traps.
Vatican in 2024.
Cue anime girl mascots.
That's...
It's the same thing.
Who do you think is guarding the secret underground death traps now?
Huh?
Who do you think is guarding it now?
It's a whole ass keyblade.
You're right!
Actually.
Nice.
It really is a keyblade.
Do you know anything girl?
Ok, time to do...
The second challenge.
This one.
Pull!
Alex, thank you so much for 8 months.
She's trying her best.
You know what?
She knows more than me.
But her comments are very unnecessary I would say.
Like yeah Gina, we know.
We know it moved.
That's why I pulled the lever.
That's why I did that.
Are those swords?
What are these?
It looks like it was part of a trial and they were flailing around.
Ok Vatican construction team.
We are creating death traps.
Alright, person number 1.
What is your suggested death trap?
I propose we have swinging axes from the ceiling that you must parkour to and from.
Great suggestion.
It is a test of one's agility.
Ok, person number 2.
What do you think should be our proposed death trap?
I think we should have a room full of fire that you must traverse through to prove your purity.
And then you stick in some stone blocks.
I like it.
It exemplifies someone's dexterity.
Third person.
What do you think should be the Vatican's death trap?
Yeah, I just think we should have a bunch of swords on chains and they flail around.
Imagine you go into a room and there are just swords on chains all over the place.
What do these do?
I can't.
As God intended.
Amen.
So glad we don't have to go through these.
Guy created the most elaborate death trap of them all.
What's this?
I thought those were monkeys.
What's in here?
Gina, don't follow me.
Thank you.
Place.
Oh, I'm sequence breaking.
I'm sequence breaking, my bad.
Okay.
What is your favorite death trap, Minto?
She's really intrigued by this stone wall.
Okay, don't roll your eyes at me, Gina.
Oh, a secret!
Oh my God.
We got the sussy relic.
Enemy girls guard ancient relics now.
Minto is sitting in a room full of G-Stuffs.
What are you doing in here?
What are you looking at?
Alright, onward!
Maybe I wasn't sequence breaking.
She is too comfortable with walking on top of this stuff.
She is way too...too comfortable.
Wow!
Go, Gia!
Here?
Is there something I need to pull?
The light guide my path.
Gold path trial.
Where is she going?
Do I follow her?
Okay, I'm following her.
Oh, just kidding.
The light guide your...oh, maybe I go pull the thing.
Alright.
They are so creepy!
The lighting is so awesome.
Where did she go?
Okay.
What's this?
The holy grail?
I think that would have to be the Henya cup.
I can't just not...
I would do anything to have just a dribble of anything out of my Kamiyoshi cup.
Okay, hold on.
I'm confused.
Okay, let the light guide your path.
But...
Do I have to make them...
light up?
But they don't...
I'm confused.
If I could just...a little bit from, you know...
The cup of my Kamiyoshi.
Okay.
Oh, we can't go through here, can we?
Okay, only this side.
I don't understand if it's supposed to look a certain way, you know.
Okay, this one doesn't have a thing, so...
It's correct?
How am I supposed to know what's the right one?
Pull the lever and see how it looks behind?
I get hurt?
I could try really fast.
I think...
Get away from there!
Nothing changes.
They light up, but this one is not lit up.
And I can't move it.
So it must be like the quote on quote example, right?
Okay.
Okay, it does light up.
Nevermind.
I can't move the other window.
Nice, okay.
And...
This one I also can't move.
Maybe...
The other door opened.
Or it didn't do that.
I hope you have a good holiday with the Mintoes.
Snake surfing!
If you were to choose between Snake's cake and Jetstream Sam's cake, which would you choose?
That's a great question.
Look up?
Cameras don't look up?
Let the whip work.
There's like nothing here.
There's not even a little guy.
That's a great question.
I think between the two...
I really like Sam.
How do I go up there?
How do I get up there?
I have to say these sounds are...
Wait.
These sounds seem pretty demonic.
Yeah,
of course I have to whip it you guys, but I have to like...
It's not like I just whip it good.
Whip it good.
I have to like...
You have to also...
I can't go down.
You have to also have the ability to do it.
OK, go down Indy.
Indy, go down.
Oh, there we go.
Maybe... Can I swing over there?
Is it too far?
Oh god.
I think it's too far.
The fur... Left?
Is there an... Oh!
Can I swing to that?
Ouch.
I don't... Can I grab onto that?
I don't think I can.
OK, hold on.
Is there anything else that I can...
How do I get from all the way over here to there?
OK, hold on.
I can absolutely grab onto it.
Onto that?
OK.
OK, let me try again.
Let me go... OK.
Oh!
Got it perfectly!
OK.
Climb it up baby.
Nice!
You are going to return it to where it was, right Gina?
I had it perfectly placed.
That's right.
You really are the divine comedy.
What did I... What did I do?
Through!
Nice.
OK.
Easy.
I think I'm the best at this.
Nice.
Easy.
Everything is lit up.
You are really yanking my chain.
You are really pulling my chain.
OK.
Oh my God.
Gina, are you good?
Are you OK?
I think this should be it.
Let's pull the lever!
Yeah, I actually did it.
And here we are.
Oh, let me take my photo.
That's a gun.
Wait.
Camera.
You think she is going to betray me guys?
You think she is going to betray me?
Hope you are doing good and have a nice holiday.
Thank you!
You too Toa!
Thank you so much.
You think these are going to turn around?
Be super freaky?
Their mouths!
They are not freaky!
They are metal as hell!
Oh my God!
Gina, get out.
You are ruining the view.
Does she seem like the type who will betray you?
Honestly, she doesn't really give that kind of vibe.
But you know.
You never know.
Perfect.
So I like how all of these just kind of hope and assume that you have a whip to be able to...
Because how are you supposed to get that otherwise?
Oh, for giants.
You are right.
It's tall for the giants.
These guys are also like...
Kingdom!
It's even the door to darkness.
I don't think every female character betrays Indy.
Okay.
Search for clues.
You don't want to take a picture of this?
I'm scared.
Lights?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I'm a little freaked out.
Metatron.
You guys, I think this might be Kingdom Hearts.
This
is so awesome looking.
Nice rear.
What is she doing?
Okay, we are just wandering around.
Oh, there is a door over here.
Why is it saving?
I'm scared.
Where the hell did you come from?
Millage.
What?
What did you hear?
I didn't hear anything.
History of the Crusades.
An old book concerning the history of the Crusades written sometime in medieval times.
Sometime in medieval times.
It's full title is History of the Crusades and the Sacred Vessels of the Great Reclamation.
We don't want that.
You don't want to take that Indy.
It's not important enough to you.
Wow, it's got the little... it's got loss on it.
Me anytime I see a vaguely circular set piece of paper.
This is the great circle.
Oh yeah!
I keep forgetting about the circle.
Imagine this is morning view.
Very old bible that cannot be found in the historic records of the different versions of the sacred text.
Yeah, who's here?
And they left bread.
Am I going to eat the bread?
Hell yeah I am.
I'm just going to take their bread.
Yeah, could be really old bread.
Who knows?
Who cares?
Why is this painting so large?
So randomly placed.
Oh, what's this?
Paper?
What are these writings?
Burnt paper with symbols of unknown origin.
Okay.
Oh, I found something important.
Do you know it?
Wow.
Oh my god.
That looks like the most complicated language ever.
My dad.
Oh!
Your sister.
That looks so complicated.
Oh my god.
This curious book contains unusual prayers not seen in any traditional religious sources.
How curious.
What's this?
This looks like regular writing.
Locus.
Traveled to the new world and located the word in a school.
Oh, the paper looks so modern.
I thought that it was like the people that were here.
Brother Locus received minimal injuries during retrieval.
I don't know about minimal.
It appears in the form of a cat and has been placed in the treasury of esoteric artifacts.
We have to find this treasury, Gina.
Maybe there are some clues in here.
That's what I said.
Just punch him.
Punch it in.
Set it aflame.
Do something.
I don't know.
Weren't you supposed to watch guard?
Keep guard, girl.
Nephilim.
Like Iris?
She's a giant?
Iris.
It's Iris.
I forgot she was a Nephilim.
Vatican's secrets.
What?
How did you open that?
You got this, Gina.
You got this.
Gina,
I'm so sorry.
Can you help me out?
Oh no!
Get in!
Wait, what do you mean someone's coming?
I didn't get to investigate the other area.
My British guard.
It was the rat.
This is definitely a door.
No.
What do we need to push?
Opportunity dogs, Vito.
What is that?
Oh whoops.
Oh here it is.
Swipe?
You had a great time.
I still have the pendant.
That's the wrong thing.
Turn!
The treasury!
Maybe?
Looks pretty...
Jackpot baby!
I just realized I can look around during the cutscenes.
What are you looking at?
I don't know.
We literally just heard somebody walking.
Oh she's gonna betray us.
Gina, is it because I...
Is it because I whiffed too hard?
Wow.
Look at that.
Shut up.
Hold on.
I'm exploring.
She's gearing up for betrayal.
That's the most sus thing I've seen her do.
What is this?
A knot mirror.
Maybe I'm a vampire.
I'm looking around.
Treasure chamber.
Yeah.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, they even just have some shells.
Well...
Aren't you just saying...
That the thing I wanted is over there?
Oh my gosh, this is so awesome!
It feels like Chiara's outfit.
Is that a gnome?
I want this rat.
Hello Gina.
Betrayer.
Gosh, she's like...
These guys stink.
Oh wow, there's even paintings on the wall.
What's this one?
Titty lion.
I'm liking all the stuff that I'm seeing.
There's nothing here for me to take?
No little among us?
Nothing?
Lower thy gaze.
Her eyes are up there though.
What is this?
Quite the hoarder these giants are.
Oh my god!
That's...
That's so cursed!
Ok Gina, I don't think there's anything here.
This is scary as hell.
I don't like that one.
Is there a giant underneath that?
Is this alive?
You think this is alive?
You think this is...
Ok.
Maybe not.
Where are you at?
Weeping angel.
Oh you found it.
That looks exactly like a cat mummy.
What the hell is this thing?
Forget the cat mummy.
I need the story of everything else on this shelf.
I don't care about the cat...
The cat mummy looks exactly like a cat mummy.
What was Indy trying to be like so...
Takes a trained eye.
But this?
What do you even describe that as?
Goblin.
That's a minky.
I want it so bad.
I want it.
Oh wow, it's much bigger than I thought it would be.
Aww.
That's... that's a real life giant, Dr. Jones.
Yep.
You're Locus, right?
But... but they're trying to do bad with him.
Sure.
Bad first impressions.
On all that.
But that's water under the bridge.
Doesn't mean that we can't still talk this out like...
Civilization.
Oh my god.
She just threw him back at him.
Am I gonna have to fight this thing?
Oh my god.
What do you mean over here?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Take him.
Take him...
You stole from me first!
Oh my god.
I'm repeatedly pressing.
Gina, you can help.
Oh my god.
Punch him.
Are we trying?
Damn.
He doesn't take any hit.
You do have a gun.
True!
Oh wait.
How do I switch to my gun?
There we go.
Revolver.
Oh Gina, you might wanna...
You might wanna get out of the way for that one.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Ow!
Where's my hitbox?
Oh my god.
Where the...
This is so goofy looking.
Oh my god.
He hit her.
Is he bulletproof?
How am I supposed to...
Oh my god.
I don't know how to...
I feel like I'm gonna have to redo this part, but...
Ow!
My god!
I'm gonna... I'm gonna die for sure, but...
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I don't think it's a matter of blocking, cause like...
This guy... Oh my god, I'm finally...
Can I?
Ok, thank you.
Thanks Gina.
She can take a hit.
Oh god!
Oh no she can't!
Oh my god!
I'm blocking.
I'm trying to... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I can't tell... Is that me?
Who's...
No!
Oh Indy.
Indy.
What the hell?
I'm gonna die for real.
Girl, please.
Gina, please.
Gina, my heartbeat.
I can hear it in my ears.
Oh my god.
Can you do something about him?
Oh he's coming after me!
Oh my god.
Oh he's like the final boss of CQC.
He's just like the boss for real.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Keep getting his ass!
Tie him up!
Oh my god.
I did it.
Yeah!
First try!
Shoot him!
He's huge.
Oh John!
Benito?
Bravo.
It's Amarek!
Papa?
Is this...
This doesn't sound Italian.
What the...
It's German.
Okay, that's what I was gonna say.
I know he's German.
Does this guy know German too?
They just all speak in different languages?
He's so scary looking.
Oh my god.
Stop spitting.
Why do you look like that?
Oh no!
He's got the cat!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's so painful.
You belonged in a museum!
I can't believe... Wait, so there was never a mummy in there to begin with?
Octum!
Don't take the... wait.
Wait, where's our Goblin?
He's disappeared!
You guys, I think he came to life!
The Great Circle!
And our Goblin is gone!
And there aren't even all of them.
Don't worry, father.
There are only four pieces left to be found.
Send him on them, you know?
No, you should have had him attack them.
I have to warn you, Herr Voss.
The relics are dangerous.
They are supposed to protect forces that are not of this world.
So he does know their purpose.
That's when the Ark didn't make it.
Gotta go after the Great Circle.
As soon as we have all the relics, our nations will be unstoppable.
He looks so pleased.
If one freaky mythical object doesn't work, you go after...
You go after the next freaky...
freaky thing.
Yeah, you feel bad now, Papa Ventura?
Stupid.
Impressive that they have accents in German speech, Italian speaking German.
Nice detail.
So it wasn't us that took the cat, so you can...
Oh.
No, our cat.
Is he there?
Oh
my god!
That's so sad!
Ok, hold on, I'm mourning, please!
Oh wow, I didn't even see this room.
These are so scary, why are they facing the wall?
This is so... I hate, I hate, I hate sheet ghosts, they scare me.
Oh, Indiana Jones Revengeance, right?
Oh, Rosie's letter.
Hold on!
If I just listened to you, I would have never gotten this!
To the head of the Vatican treasure chamber collection.
Evidence has emerged that Ventura has been conspiring with Mussolini to let him into the chamber.
It is not a far fetched thought that it is Ventura himself who is somehow responsible for the Pope's current condition.
I think we could have deduced that ourselves.
Goblin Slayer!
No!
Do you still have it?
No, I threw it away.
We have to act quickly, or some of the most holy items could end up in the wrong hands.
We have to tread lightly, or we risk causing a political crisis that could spiral out of control.
Do you still have it?
Removing the keys from Ventura's possession could buy us some time.
I hope we are not too late.
Dante wrote... Dante!
If the Vatican's secret agency tried to stop Ventura...
Do you still have it?
Hold on, I need more bandages.
What's this?
Grab it.
What do we have here?
Ziggurat dig report.
I cannot open the door.
Oh my god, she is so annoying!
Shut up!
Hold on, Cheetah!
The expedition to Ur-Iraq, led by Peruvian archaeologist Andres Silvio Uribe, was carefully monitored by Vatican agents to ensure the preservation of its secrets.
Two young archaeologists, Henry Jones Jr. and Rene Belloc, were also present on the site.
I'm gonna shoot her.
Uribe's staff discovered a previously unknown chamber along with several artifacts.
Among them was a stone tablet related to the Great Circle uncovered by Henry Jones Jr.
The item was acquired by the VSA agent without rousing attention as plenty of more mundane but also more valuable items were found by Uribe's team.
Rene Belloc proceeded to steal and later sell these artifacts which helped to mask the theft of the tablet.
The loss of the artifacts damaged Dr. Uribe's reputation and no further inquiry was made on the loss of the stone tablet.
Ok, God.
Ok, I'm gonna open the door for you and then I'm gonna look through the rest of the room.
I swear to God, Gina.
I swear to God.
I have enough bullets.
I'm working on it, lady!
Do what you want.
I've had a run in with the Nazis before and trust me, it ain't a walk in the park.
Ok, then.
Let's see if you can keep up.
What do you mean if I can keep up?
Wait, no!
I didn't finish looking through the room.
Oh my God, now we're so far away.
That damn smile.
Oh, and it's locked.
Oh, are they gonna go up and run into Indiana Jones?
It's just us hitching a ride probably.
Uh...
Who?
What do you mean who?
Do I...
Catch the airship.
I'm swinging, I'm swinging, I'm swinging.
And jump.
Good job, Indy.
Wait, can I jump from here?
I imagine I can.
Oh God, I'm scared.
Nice.
Nothing?
Oh my God.
Indy, don't fall.
Nice.
I'm so good.
Yeah, it's a big rat.
Oh my God, it's so beautiful.
Rooftop of St. Peter's Basilica.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Wait, how did I...
Please, let me up.
Let me up.
Uppies?
Uppies, please.
Wait, I can't go any other way.
There we go.
Which... I think I want to go... I don't want to be up there, do I?
Oh yes, I do.
That's where the white paint is.
Oh, what's down here though?
Is there anything?
Feels like there is something.
Maybe not.
Arby!
What a view.
Good job, Indy.
Press L to climb faster.
Okay, now... Up.
Up.
Oh God, oh God.
Stop moving, Indy.
Rest your little arms.
Oh.
Oh!
Yay!
Now to upgrade your grip gauge.
I don't think that was... The grip gauge is only for... The one that I have left is only for enemies.
Oh my gosh, so scary.
Climbing.
We're climbing.
In we go.
And in we...
Dork.
What's that sound?
Oh, they're giving me more bullets.
I could probably shoot this guy.
Why don't I have any more bullets?
It's okay.
I'm safe.
Probably.
Are they going to come around?
Watch where you're shooting, buddy.
Hello?
That guy took that bullet like a champ.
I think we're fine.
Maybe.
Moving on.
Okay.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Ah, thank you.
Master of stealth.
Absolutely.
What are the repair kits for?
I keep grabbing them, but I have no idea what they're for.
Do they think they see me under...
They're really... They're really... I really confused them.
You can repair weapons.
Oh, this door is blocked.
Okay, hold on.
Where do we go up from?
It looks like about here.
Here I go up from...
Jump.
Jump, Indy.
Oh, my goodness.
Come on, Indiana Jones.
And jump.
There we go.
But, like, if I can't shoot them through the thing...
They shouldn't be able to shoot me through the stairs.
Right?
Like, that's just how it should work.
Where do I... Oh.
Huh?
Where do I go from here?
Oh, over there.
Okay, I see.
What do you mean, huh?
Oh.
Did he hear me?
Hey!
Oh, my God.
He's got a gun.
Oh, shit.
I'm dead.
So... Oh, my God.
All the way here?
Okay, so, funny story.
These guys hit like crazy hard.
Damn.
Well, I'm reloading right now.
Oh, damn.
They hit like crazy.
Let's eat.
Or let's bandage and eat and stuff.
Well, I took that one guy down with one bullet, so that was pretty good.
But everything else was not so good.
Wow, I can't believe they...
I can't believe they make you go all the way back over here.
Like, I feel like they should let you through.
At least, like, have the same save point up there.
That's how I feel it should be.
But what do I know?
What do I know?
Go, Indy, go.
Guns are lethal.
Yeah, but in video games, they're not.
In video games, guns...
You can take, like, five bullets in video games.
That's all I'm saying.
Here we go.
And in.
The antidote.
That's...
That's two.
Let's do that.
Take more stuff.
But to be fair, my health wasn't, like, all the way.
So, like, it could have been that too.
Okay, guys.
I gotta... wait.
Does this pause the game?
Not quite sure.
I gotta go to the bathroom.
I gotta go to the little ghost's room.
So you just chill right here.
And I'll be right back, okay?
You guys just hang out.
And we won't get caught.
We'll be fine.
Okay.
Keep an eye out.
Keep an eye out for me, okay?
Don't be scared.
There's nothing to be scared of, okay?
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Sorry about that.
I'm back.
Sorry.
I couldn't find my cat.
And then...
Usually she's, like, in a window, but she was under my bed.
I like to check on my cats when I take a break.
Oh, whoops.
Wrong way.
Okay.
Alright.
Indeed.
Don't make so much noise.
Oh, bless you.
Bless you.
God, these guys are...
I could take him out.
I could take him out right now.
Actually, that probably would have been perfect.
Oh, I'm still gone fishing.
Thank you.
I should have done it.
Maybe I should.
I mean, they give me more bullets.
Alright, once he comes back...
Once he comes back, we'll take him out.
And then the other guys will come over and we'll take those guys out.
And then the ghost will be clear.
And it'll be...
I don't know if they'll see me.
How did he see me?
Oh, there he is.
What do you mean?
You literally shot at me, mister.
Hello?
Nothing here.
No way.
Hello?
Anybody gonna come right here?
All I hear is...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, so there's three.
At least.
Wait, how did that one guy see me through here?
He's gone by now?
How did he see me through there?
Um,
I don't... I'm not quite...
Search is off?
Okay, I'm not quite sure what to do here.
Um...
That was cool?
Or did he see me?
No, he didn't see me through there.
Maybe the next guy will come and check out the window.
Oh, guns a-blazin'?
Yeah, but I'll die.
If I die, I don't want to do all the parkour stuff again.
Oh wait, that's the dead guy.
Okay.
Nevermind, that's the guy we shot.
Okay, okay.
You can stealth take down these guys pretty easily.
I don't have a weapon or anything though.
To take them down with.
I want them to leave.
Okay,
my fists...
Alright, alright.
I'm scared, these guys scare me.
They have guns.
It's the first time I think we've dealt with guns.
Alright, give them hands.
Alright, let's go give them hands!
Am I crouched?
Bless you.
Oh my god, he scared me.
Anybody else?
Maybe I'll just go.
Take that.
Not the body.
I don't care about that.
Nice.
I've got hands.
Open fire where?
No!
Anyway.
Oh god, I love beating people up.
What a view.
No wonder you wanted this area.
Mine.
Mine now.
Let's go.
Minky sweet.
Anything else over here?
I hear someone moving.
I better not have.
Ok, we know there is one more guy at least.
Now it's a blunt weapon.
Oh I saved.
Nice.
Wait, there was nothing else?
No items for us to collect?
Nothing?
I love how you can pick up so many things in this game.
There is so many things you can use as a weapon in this game.
Wow, a biotic info!
Thank you so much for the tech gifted.
Thank you!
Wish I could take their uniforms.
Can I have another disguise now please?
Ok.
A toilet plunger.
Yeah, like...
I would just be embarrassed if I were beaten up with a toilet plunger.
I think I would give up.
Ok, here we go.
What's this?
Drinking on the job?
Sorry.
Our strut.
Why are you not in your cassock?
And not in the library with Father Antonio?
Funny.
Just want to check out the view.
Yeah.
You know us Americans, always knows when about.
With a gun and a whip.
You'd be surprised how often it comes in handy.
He whimpered at me.
Traitors.
Conspirators.
Liars!
And now I also have to deal with spies?
Oh I'm no spy.
Do I still have my gun?
Did we bring him with us?
Demon!
That was like the weakest looking punch ever.
It was like hitting a cloud.
Oh my god, he is just tall.
I guess we are buds now.
Demon!
Indy, how do we get up there?
Indy!
Damn.
Yeah.
Demon!
How many giants are there?
Oh my god.
Father Antonio...
I think we are leaving Italy.
Sayonara!
Are we going to hold on the entire time?
Please.
Might want to swing...
Back and forth...
Until we do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Okay, watch my...
Watch my...
What's it called?
Can I get to that?
Okay, X.
X?
How the hell?
It is so impressive how much he sounds like young Harrison Ford.
Are we...
We are climbing again.
He sounds so much like young Harrison Ford.
It's so crazy.
Okay!
The Great Circle is the biggest mystery in all of archeology.
Do you even know what it is?
Some kind of a fancy ring you are going to put in your museum perhaps?
No.
What is it?
What?
Do you have your lipstick?
Give it to me.
Indirect kiss.
That's the Earth.
Okay, I...
The Great Circle is the Earth.
Oh,
Uranus.
Maybe it's just a fluke.
Or maybe Vos found something that connects these stone relics to the Great Circle.
Her poor lipstick is unusable now.
They only care about power.
It's circular in shape.
Oh,
Saturn.
I have to find my sister.
It was for the bit, okay?
Don't worry about it.
Uranus really does have rings though.
Doesn't it actually?
I thought so.
They are just not as pronounced as Saturn's.
Yeah!
So I was...
You know what?
I knew I was right.
I was like wait a second.
Gosh, you guys make me feel like I'm stupid.
They are just not as pronounced.
Cool.
They let you keep your hair?
Isn't that how you've been picking locks?
He was looking at her so like...
You could stab him right now.
So did she betray us or not?
She was acting so sussy before.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Giza!
The map.
Okay, let's go.
Uh oh.
The nachos.
Doink.
Uh oh.
I'll read all this later.
I'll read this later.
Doink.
Oh, I'm sure it is.
Wait, what else is there?
Doink.
I don't know if this is timed or not.
Item limit reach?
What am I trying to grab?
You're in my way.
Oh, this is a repair thing?
Okay.
Doink.
Nice.
Oh, did that just open?
Okay, we're fine.
Here?
I'm literally robbing them blind first.
Okay.
Yay!
Oh.
I think we can make it.
Just...leave.
I love that we're taking this big ol' blimp over here.
Yeah, tuck and roll.
Exactly.
Welcome to Giza.
Really?
Ganz.
I really like that they kept the voices and...
the original language.
He's spitting bars.
This guy looks like...
He even has Huey's glasses.
Who should be on this blimp?
Pop
his tires.
Are you going to go?
Okay.
Okie dokie.
How are we going to sneak around here?
Oh boy.
I guess it's just like in the movies where they just snuck around in plain sight.
Nice.
Plain sight, baby.
How many vases will be broken in this game?
Before someone is satisfied.
Oh my god, give these poor guys some shoes, please.
Oh.
Alright.
And we're here.
Blue tent in a workers area.
Flag?
What flag?
Oh, that flag.
Okay.
Or, I could adventure around.
I'm Indiana Jones.
Wow!
We're in the desert!
Oh my god!
All the
items I've seen.
Stop yelling at me.
It's kind of insufferable.
Oh my god, it's so cool!
So,
blue tent.
Oh, up here.
Anything here?
What is this?
Oh, that's for a bottle.
Okie dokie, blue.
That one over there?
The blue tent.
What are those?
Oh.
This is the blue tent?
Nice.
Wow!
Worst game backseater I've ever seen.
She's so insufferable.
I thought, what's her name?
From...
From Temple of Doom was annoying.
But like, she's just...
Wow.
Can I just like, run around here?
Or will people get mad at me?
Am I supposed to be secretive here?
I feel like I should be.
But um, I'm just gonna walk the road.
Nobody else is here.
I might...
I'll try and be a little secret.
If I walk with authority...
Oh, that's a...
If I...
If I walk with authority...
Nobody will question me.
What do you mean, what sound?
I didn't do anything!
I'm literally walking!
Authority.
Oh my god!
Hey, chill out man!
Chill out!
God!
Anyway...
Everything's fine!
Carry on!
Walk with authority.
Authority.
Everybody is shuffling.
I don't think you know what you're doing.
Why did you...
Why did you walk past me like that?
I really wanted to see the camel.
Look how cute they are!
Why do they look so... Oh my goodness!
Gina, go away!
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I'm not gonna steal from you guys, but...
If you have anything you're willing to offer...
Minto...
I'll gladly take it.
Nicely detailed camel.
Yeah, he's really cute.
I love how he's like, what's that sound?
As if I'm not just literally taking a step.
Indiana Jones would be amazing in the modern day.
He would be the best...
You know those YouTubers that are like, I went to Egypt and...
I'm just a dude and everybody was shook that I could speak the language.
He would kill it.
Oh, you guys got any bandages?
Donation box?
Wait, how did we never unlock this?
Oh, are you okay?
You okay?
What's that sound?
It's the sound of Indiana Jones walking confidently and not shuffling like a nerd.
And polyglot...
Oh, that's the camel!
I thought it was your stomach or something.
He's got the worst case of IBS ever.
Wait, who said that?
Oh, hello!
You got...oh, what's up?
How are the Germans treating you?
Well, to tell you the truth, they are being quite difficult.
They only give me the bare minimum in terms of medical equipment.
I don't even have any medicine.
And I know for a fact the Germans have a supply, but they won't share.
And what if someone were to stumble upon some unattended German medicine?
Where's my bro Sarla?
Yeah, where's Sarla?
Then I would advise that someone deliver it here.
I would make sure it's put to good use.
I have some leftovers from, you know, the Vatican.
It's still good medicine.
If you want that.
New discovery.
What do you need?
What do you want?
Oh, Moxie!
Wait, what do you mean I only have five?
Okay, we gotta find the bottles.
Oh my god.
This guy is going through it.
I think he's got whatever they had in Italy.
I can't stop hearing their stomachs.
Oh, I'm taking pictures of them?
This is messed up.
Say cheese, sick man.
Who am I taking?
Oh, a picture of him.
That would be so messed up.
Nice and close.
45 points!
Nice.
Are there any more guys to beat up?
Was there only two guys in this whole camp?
Surely not.
Those are the only two that came running at me though.
Busy guy.
Anyone in here?
No one?
No one in there?
I'm looking for medicine bottles.
You guys wouldn't mind, right?
I'm eating my ancient biscottis.
Nice.
Hello.
Heard you're going to be in Aura's charity concert, congrats.
Yeah!
I will be.
She invited me, so I was like, yeah.
Sounds fun.
I will be there.
New food item.
We're collecting it all.
This place looks more difficult to find stuff.
Not gonna lie.
Hello.
Oh, can I have that?
Oh, I thought it was food.
Oh.
A prickly pear.
I thought it was like a...
I don't... I thought it was like a bread stick or something.
What do you mean coming through?
You are sitting on your ass.
Who are you talking to?
Are we just going to ignore the...
the two knocked out guys or...
Are these my footprints?
No.
Whose footprints are these?
Bread flute.
Delicious.
Melon pon.
You don't mind, do you sir?
Gina's out here.
Or maybe she's not.
I don't know where she is.
Oh, there she is.
What are you doing, girl?
I don't think she even knows.
I miss melon pon.
I can't get it where I'm at.
No, you can try and probably make it.
It doesn't seem very difficult.
What, it's just sugar... something, something mixed together.
Wow, look at all the bananas and corn.
I'm hungry.
Gonna have to eat soon.
Yeah, we're just going to ignore these guys.
That's fine.
This camp is mine now.
Hello.
Okay, this is how we...
Great sphinx.
Oh, spoilers, spoilers.
So we will get a uniform.
Eventually.
Then we'll go in and steal all their stuff.
Sorry.
Oh, where are they?
Who's seeing me?
That guy over there is Hawkeyes?
It looked like I could go up there.
Maybe not.
Bless you.
Thank you!
Oh gosh, you guys, I'm getting what they had in Italy.
Not the Vatican.
I've got what they had!
I'm in trouble.
Who's talking to me?
I think I'm in trouble.
It's probably if you speak Italian.
You get it.
And I said, No!
Sorry, I know I'm doing a lot of exploring.
Is that not bread?
I'm so hungry.
What the...
How?
Don't bullshit me game.
There's no way.
Carry twice the amount of bread!
Huge, huge if real.
Bread basket.
Saying naan bread is like saying bread bread.
Shut up.
I was just clarifying.
Since we have someone in the chat named Naan.
Oh my god.
No.
Chai tea moment.
I'm just trying not to confuse anybody.
I think he can still see me.
Oh!
It's...
The kitchen.
Say cheese!
Hold on.
Say...
Don't...
Don't facepalm me.
Say nanos!
Nanos!
Can I take any of these?
Are those loquats?
This guy is playing Minecraft.
They do have shoes.
I think I'm lost now.
This camp is huge.
And I haven't found a single medicine bottle.
Wait, I came over here before.
Did I?
I think.
I haven't found anything to steal.
Hello, sir.
Don't mind me.
Good day to you.
Rough, huh?
It's okay.
You'll get through it.
Don't worry.
Is she okay?
I believe in you.
Just looking for stuff to steal.
At least we got the...
Oh, see?
Like this.
We're in.
Cookie.
She's having a day.
Really, she's going through it.
Okay,
let's go back to her contact.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Cookie.
We can go through here and then around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Good job.
Camel.
Okey dokey.
She's beautiful.
Famous archaeologist.
I like her glasses a lot.
She's got a mole, too.
Am I sensing...?
I'm glad to hear you say that.
Why, thank you.
She doesn't look like a narwhal.
Oh, have a look around, Dr. Jones.
She's just not in the water enough.
It's nawal.
Not narwhal.
You have a very sharp eye for quality.
Just trinkets I've collected on my travels.
Thank you, Daniel.
The Nazis think it's a conduit of some kind of power, correct?
Boss certainly does.
He believes it will secure his place in history.
Everything's a competition with that guy.
I'm choosing my sister to cross the finish line.
My roommate's senses are tingling.
Everything is predestined and pre-written.
As the Egyptians would say.
Snakes!
Mind-feeding of Cyrus, Dr. Jones.
I don't think he's hungry.
Scared of snakes, Dr. Jones?
Must be a problem in your line of work.
Why'd it have to be snakes?
Nothing would make me happier than feeding your snake, David Wall.
Oh, are we actually?
Feed Osiris!
Give him just a little snack.
That should be enough.
A little snake?
A little snerk?
I want to see him.
He's not in there.
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god, he's precious!
Look at that little guy.
His little tongue.
Oh my god, he's so cute!
Hold on with the tongue.
Ow!
Dang it.
What do you mean it's no good?
I'm trying, Indy.
I'm trying.
Maybe you're the one who's like, I don't want to get closer.
How is that any better?
You don't even see him.
Charming.
Is this his food?
He looks terrified.
One of my spies smuggled this out of the Nazi compound.
Oh, I thought he ate the peppers.
That doesn't seem like a very snake food.
Signed by Adolf Hitler.
An obnoxious little twit.
Dr. Laura Lombardi.
She's on the list of the participants?
Couldn't find any description of this experiment.
Like how you see a shadow in the background?
My German is a tad rusty.
Where did you get yourself into, Laura?
She was so absorbed in her work when we lived in Berlin.
She was never really present.
She never was in the moment.
What are you trying to say, huh?
Well, I'm still here for her.
Doing everything I can, even though...
Voss.
Has an office in the Nazi compound.
Perhaps we can find more information there.
Is he okay?
Let's give him the beetle.
This is how he dies.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
I mean your snake is a little aggressive.
The what?
This room is so cozy.
I know what she means.
It's just, you know...
Oh god, no.
Wait,
what?
Geomantic analysis.
Observations on the geomantic properties of the pyramids.
The alignment of the two smaller pyramids in relation to the Great Pyramid must be significant.
Notice the number of miniature pyramids and how they are arranged.
A very peculiar pattern.
Did the ancient Egyptians see some sort of divine properties in this location?
What secrets is the ground beneath the hot sands we walk on hiding?
Okay, I'm gonna just take your...
I'm just gonna take your diary entry.
Who's this?
Scarlet Arrow.
What?
Wait, no, you didn't explain it.
You didn't finish saying it.
I think she's murderous.
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe she's just murderous.
Who's this?
British Egyptologist Margaret.
A lovely lady.
I just took a picture.
I'm just taking all your stuff, honestly.
Alright, time to observe this rubbing.
Yeah, that's what she just said.
Cursed with a terrible power, according to the old Egyptian legend.
Grapes.
It's been lost for thousands of years.
No one's known where to look.
I want some grapes.
So why does Vos think that the idol is here in Giza?
Perhaps he thinks old Khufu had it.
Khufu built the Great Pyramid as his personal tomb.
If he did have the idol, then he would...
He would want to hide its power from the world.
The power of the stone.
Dame Nawal, you're a genius.
Am I?
A cat mummy.
Sorry.
The stones at the Great Circle were found inside various ancient relics.
Which could mean the idol of Ra contains another one of those stones.
Bravo!
I take it you won't just idly wait here for your work passes.
Yeah, we'll leave.
An agent of mine purloined this excavation map from the Nazi camp.
Oh yeah, thank you.
I'll give you an updated view of the surroundings here in Giza.
You sound so sarcastic.
Why is the map in this extravagant box?
Thank you.
You could have just given me the paper.
Detailed map.
Thank you.
Wasn't Khufu's grave robbed within a few decades of his death though?
I can use this to listen to the Nazi's recommendations.
Historical fiction.
Splendid idea.
Be my guest.
Don't think about it.
I don't know if that's true or not.
But if it is true, just don't worry about it.
That was his decoy grave.
Yeah, it's a video game.
Aw,
the music.
I'll do my best.
As long as I end up in a museum.
Take yourself serious.
I belong in a museum.
Oh god.
Stele number 1.
Stele number 2.
Is in the Sphinx.
Stele number 3.
Beneath... Oh wait.
Stele number 2 is east of the Sphinx.
Stele number 3 is...
Beneath the Sphinx.
Stele number 4.
West of the village.
Stele number 5.
South of the mortuary temple.
X marked flag.
Hello Minto Jones.
I officially turned into a young old man today.
Gosuu!
Can you wish these old bones a happy birthday please and thank you?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Gosuu.
Hey!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Since we grabbed this...
I'm gonna be right back.
I'm gonna go grab some food real quick.
We're gonna have a quick little dinner intermission.
I won't eat for so long though.
I'm just gonna grab the food and...
Eat a bit.
And stuff, stuff, stuff.
I'll be right back.
Food break, food break.
But I'll be eating here.
We'll talk and stuff.
I'm just gonna go grab it.
And some more drink.
Some more tea.
Okay, okay, okay.
BRB.
I'm back.
I have to figure out where I put this.
When I was out earlier I got myself a taco bowl.
And now...
I don't know where to put it.
There.
Okay.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
A taco bowl.
Not Taco Bell.
Taco Be-Bowl.
How's the game so far?
I heard it was dope.
It's so fun!
It's so good.
It's so silly.
In all the best ways.
Taco Bowl.
I love these radio sounds in my right ear.
Very nice.
I'm just gonna take a quick...
Quick little break so I don't get super...
Super crazy hungry and like...
Ah, I'm shaking.
It is very India.
Very...
Indiana Jones.
Hold on, I'm gonna go away from this area.
Okay.
Hold on, I'm eating.
Oh no, she's gonna not shut up, is she?
She's not gonna shut up, is she?
We named the dog Mint?
Thanks for all the streams this year, Minto.
What?
Oh my god.
That's the second time someone's named their dog after me.
Yay!
I wanna see...
Doggo...
Dog...
Dog...Minto.
I would like to see him.
Okay, India, I get it.
God, I'm coming.
Hold on, I can't...
You're making a real racket, you know that?
I'll mute so you can hear the game.
That's the boss.
Come.
Good.
Va seems very concerned about this excavation.
What is he searching for?
He said the Sanctuary of the Guardians.
Huh?
Maybe they were guardians of the Idol of Ra.
We have to investigate before he returns to the site.
What was she doing that for?
Do you have a question, ma'am?
Ma'am?
Alright, we got fieldwork.
Mr. Yoga.
New adventure!
Can I play this?
Does it have to be a weapon thing?
I was going to play it.
Alright.
So, let's see.
Sanctuary of the Guardians and then the Idol of Ra.
Remedy for all the field notes.
So, explore the Sphinx dig.
And we got to take photographs.
Okay.
I am still munch-crunching, so...
I'll do that a bit first.
And we can have this...
You think those guys got up and walked away?
You think those guys are back?
I will have a munch-crunch and we can enjoy this view.
Mmm.
Yeah, time to learn some Arabic from whatever they are saying to us.
I'll be able to say, good day to you.
Okay.
Can we stop by McDonald's?
No!
Why is my game drifting?
I'm not touching my controller.
Controller drift.
Stick drift real.
Oh my god!
Oh, this lady is fighting through the sand.
No, I want to see the pyramid.
Let's see if it happens again.
Oh no, it's fine now.
This guy is frozen.
He is...
He is playing a game of red light, green light.
And because I'm looking at him, he won't go.
I'm not looking.
Here, I'll look away.
I'll look away.
Green light!
Red light.
Oh!
Weeping angel.
I don't know if he is okay.
I'll go check on him.
Sir?
Oh my god!
Oh, I thought he was about to drop dead.
He says, I don't want this job anymore.
I don't...Oh!
Did you just...Did you just take his broom?
He's like, well, he's not gonna use it again.
I guess I will.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, sphinx dig site is...
Oh!
Behind there, right?
Okay, we'll go behind.
We'll go another way.
It's the broom that causes you to...
freeze in time.
Mystery note.
Wanted poster.
Two French speaking men disguised as diggers who have been breaking into the excavation to steal artifacts.
One of them was seen heading southeast on the road from the workers camp.
If you have any information of these men, please inform a guard or foreman at the excavation.
Oh my god!
Oh, does this not give me...I know she gave me a new mystery.
I guess I'm gonna go find them.
It's not my job.
I guess it will turn out to be.
That looks like excavation site...
over there, over yonder.
Yes, I am correct.
In my assumption.
How do I wanna sneak past the guards?
I'll just run.
No.
Oh, these are also guys.
I'm running.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Yep.
Anyway.
Good day to you.
Alright.
Here, we have to...
We have to take photos, is that what it was?
Yeah,
they need sunglasses, that's why they can't tell anything.
Stupid heads.
Oh.
Nah, you didn't hear anything.
If you did, I'm gonna punch you out.
I'm gonna punch you out.
Where'd he go?
Oh, shit.
What the hell?
Yeah.
Curious.
Curious, indeed.
Kiara was here.
Raiders.
Oh, thank you!
Wait, did Kiara raid me?
Hello!
I'm playing Indiana Jones.
And I just...
Nah, nah.
I need a weapon.
We're searching for the great circle!
I'm being really sneaky.
Trust.
Trust I'm being so sneaky.
Grab that, grab that.
Good job, good job, good job.
Good job, good job.
Hi, Cappy!
What was Kiara streaming today?
I looked.
I'd like to not see her streaming.
Oh my god.
Where's the other guy at?
Oh, they're both here.
Okay, just kidding.
Maybe I need to just...
There's three guys.
I could drop that.
Shoot.
Grab my thing.
Oh, a member is watching!
Oh my god, did he?
I was gonna...
Oh shit.
Grab that!
Oh my god, there's a lot of guys.
Why are you so weak?
Die!
I'm not gonna live.
Grab the thing!
My hat!
Where's my hat?
Lucky hat!
My hat is here.
I think we took care of the...
I think we took care of it.
I'm also half eating dinner, so...
There's some more guys.
No, that's not what I meant to do.
But for now we're good.
This game is very fun, you guys.
It feels very Indiana Jones.
If you're like, how is this game?
It's very fun.
For raiders, the fedora is like a phoenix feather.
Yeah.
It is.
It's like...
Every time you go up...
Alright, let's eat some bread.
Eat some bread.
Let's eat some fruit.
We're getting extra stamina, extra health.
Oh yeah, baby.
Oh yeah.
Alright, now we're here.
We gotta take some photos.
I'm not quite sure of what.
Oh boy, that's kinda scary.
I'm gonna look around first.
I felt we held our own pretty well there, I'm not gonna lie.
I think we did a good job.
I think we really Indiana Jones-ed it.
What is that?
Minecraft?
What is howling?
Oh, that doesn't look...
I'm as infected as...
Yeah.
India, I wouldn't crawl through there.
I've traveled here from...
On the east bank of the Nile.
How do you pronounce this?
Was as glorious as it was mysterious.
Hundreds of pyramids containing secrets I tremble to imagine.
I discovered one such secret in a tomb.
A wall covered in beautiful...
Meroe.
So, Meroe.
A Meroitic script.
Having no knowledge of this language, I attempted to interpret some of the symbols.
One of them caught my eye.
I had seen it before in a Coptic manuscript found in Alexandria.
The Idol of Ra!
Oh my goodness.
Frankly, I searched for other clues in the myriad of hieroglyphs.
And there it was.
Three pyramids, one taller than the others.
The tomb of King Khufu.
That is how I knew the legendary Idol of Ra had to be buried somewhere in Giza.
They say it is made out of pure gold.
The sun has disappeared beyond the horizon.
It's time to sleep, though I fear I shall find it difficult with all the strange noises I've been hearing at night.
Been here a while.
Where's my...
Where's my weapon?
Oh, I left it.
Alright.
I got my fists.
Anyone wanna fight?
Oh!
That guy's out!
I was...
I was too late.
Uh...
It wasn't me.
Wasn't me.
Who's talking?
In here?
How I...
No, no, no.
How?
We can go through here.
Ancient relic.
Clearly not Egyptian.
Clearly.
Oh, I think this opens that.
Oh my god.
I'll wait for him to turn around.
Go
away now, sir.
Go away now, sir.
Nice.
I think.
Wait, what?
Is he still trying to walk in here?
There's nothing... no one here.
I'm just... I'm just pulling your chin.
Oh, I think he's walking away.
Um...
Anyone else wanna mess with me?
Oh, shit.
I should've waited a couple more seconds.
No ammo.
Maybe I shouldn't have said that out loud.
Okay.
I'll get him.
Where is he?
Where are you?
Where did you go?
No ammo.
Don't go.
He's making fun of me!
What do you mean alarm whistle?
Come on.
Come on out.
I don't know how short you are!
This is out.
I think we got it.
I think we killed him.
I think we did it, guys.
It's nice and quiet.
I hear the crickets.
How did this guy get got though?
He's looking pretty... bad.
Mysterious.
So mysterious.
Thank you.
I guess we can leave.
What are the pictures I'm supposed to be taking?
Oh, my game saving.
Is that a real person?
Hello!
Hi!
Are you trying to get my attention?
What's up?
He was waving at me.
Shoot the guy dead.
I think I killed him.
What do you want?
What do you want from me?
Oh, you're a spy.
Hi, spy.
Hi.
Thank you!
He was like, hey, over here.
Okay, well, I didn't do anything in the Sphinx though.
We still haven't...
Yeah, thanks guy.
We haven't discovered anything in here.
I'm just gonna slide down gently.
Yeah, baby.
If any KFB are still here, how was the watch along?
Was Kiara so cute again today?
Hold on.
Maybe I do have to go inside.
My man's hat is glitching out.
Oh, there we go.
Do you think I can go in?
Picture, picture, picture.
The dream still...
Steely.
Anything here to Steely?
Besides the dream Steely?
Do you think I can get this guy?
I feel like I can get him.
Oh, someone heard me?
Who heard me?
Who?
Where?
Oh God, there he is!
Minky FPS VTuber!
Easy.
I'm gonna take your date.
Nice date.
Yeah,
make sure to vote for me FPS VTuber next year!
Yeah, sorry if the guns are loud.
They are loud for me too, but...
It's hard for me to like...
Keep switching between audio.
Bandages?
I'll take it.
Rob them line.
Oh my God!
Gina!
I was about to blow your head off!
No way!
Gina!
Girl!
Oh we got a disguise!
Let's go.
What is it?
Oh.
Hold on Joy.
Discovered a curious indentation on a wall.
Not sure what to make of it.
Mayor?
To take over as excavation leader from tomorrow.
He will investigate further.
Adelbert came by rambling about generators and some power failure.
I told him I had no time for his nonsense.
That man is nearly as insufferable as his brother.
Received telegram from the Vatican.
They found the artifacts.
Awaiting Vos' return.
Oh, Brandt and the Mayor.
Day 17.
I found a golden medallion.
Perhaps it could tell us how to enter the Sanctuary of the Guardians.
I'll store it in the recreational area until Vos gets back.
Mayor.
Don't have to tell me twice.
Let's get our disguise.
Yay!
Big outfit!
Now nobody will bother us.
Probably.
Hopefully.
Maybe.
They just can't look at us.
Very well.
Or they'll notice.
Yeah, I'm eating Taco Bowl.
Taco Bowl.
Not to be confused with it's funny counterpart.
Taco Bell.
Can I get over here?
I want to explore the top.
I bet there's valuables.
Oh, nice, Indy.
Nice, nice.
Oh wait, can I explore the top?
What's all this?
A waste?
Yes.
Okie dokie.
So now we're headed to... that way!
And we found some medicine bottles on the way, which is good good.
And... I think we can go up here.
And I look totally normal.
Like I am fitting in.
Ah, nobody will suspect a thing.
Over here?
This whole place?
This...
Looks kind of industrial.
I should have brought my gun.
Is that a dog?
Oh no.
Not the dog.
I'm going to pet that dog.
I'm just going to walk in with Moxie.
I'm going to walk in like I own the place.
I belong here.
Right there.
Wait, is there another entrance?
I think I walked past it.
But I belong at this place.
Is he a captain?
Better stay away from here.
Thanks for making me laugh and smile Minky.
Thank you!
Inside here?
Right?
Indiana Jones doesn't know how to use the door.
That is a door, right?
I'm just going to walk in with Moxie.
Nevermind, nevermind, nevermind.
Bless you.
Don't come over this way.
Sir!
This is my chance to go the other direction.
Now we can go the other way.
Hello, I'm here.
Hello, don't mind me.
Hello.
Me?
Ok,
sorry.
I'm giving it to you right now!
Say cheese, Ugo.
Oh, a card.
Jack card.
Why is it...what?
Jack of hearts with Gantz and Voss written on it.
Why is it a jack of hearts?
What does that mean?
Servant or knave?
Oh, they are looking at me.
Don't look at me.
Oh, it's money.
Oh, they are looking at me though.
My hand!
I'm stretching my hand.
I'm just stretching it out.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, who?
Where?
Who?
Ok, let's go back to the Sphinx.
We did what we needed to do.
We are so good at our job.
Lover Nacho subplot.
That's what I'm saying.
Can I punch this guy?
Do you think there is more than one guy in here?
I kind of want to...
Wait, it just saved.
I feel I could try and punch...
What did it say the site was?
Oh, hi.
Thank you.
Are you bored?
Are you so sad and bored?
Yeah, I should get out of here.
I'm sneaky everywhere you guys.
I'm so sneaky.
Alright, to the Sphinx.
To the Sphinx.
That's the only...
Hold on, I just want to make sure.
Yeah, our only field work currently is the sanctuary stuff.
What a way to store an ancient golden medallion.
Right?
Ok.
What are these noises in here?
Parkour.
Gina, are you still here?
Wow, you are.
Hey, I got the door.
Yep, shut up.
Ok, you can leave then.
Parkour!
Sesame.
Woah.
Are you sure about that?
What about the giant hole in the roof?
Oh, oh yeah.
Watch your step.
You can't?
I can.
Gina, you need glasses girl.
Yeah, we didn't even need the thing.
We could've...
Yeah, I don't like it.
Village market.
You are so brave.
Find a light source.
Ok.
I can't see the bottom.
Maybe.
Use your eyes.
Oh, I didn't notice this here.
Oh, sneaky.
Wheel of fortune.
Sneaky, sneaky.
Alright.
Oh, I feel like we could just...
Well, I guess the...
Big lights are attached to...
What's the word?
What?
They replaced him.
I was gonna say.
They are attached to a power source.
So probably would be difficult to...
To take one of those around.
Hello.
This is my work area.
Don't mind me.
Do not mind me.
Second.
Ok.
Hello.
Is that the right direction?
This way.
I thought by the village...
Marketplace, it meant this place.
You are so right.
I could sneak in.
I won't, but I could.
If I felt like it.
Shoot, I have to go all the way back around.
I should have checked.
I'm an idiot.
Ok.
Run, Indy.
Get those steps in, buddy.
No huffing and puffing here.
Oh no.
Where am I going?
All the way...
All the way down there.
Excuse me.
I'm just a little guy.
Trying to do his job.
Don't mind me.
Ok, so we do have now...
I thought that said Chungus.
Workers area.
And we'll get the village.
One soon.
You think that guy is still here?
The one that I shot.
Really well.
What riddles do you hold?
Don't mind me.
Oh, ok, rude.
Chungusville.
Chungus village.
I guess...
They ate him.
Probably.
Alright.
To the village.
Here's our village.
Run, Indy, run.
Oh, that was a big old dog.
What do you mean?
A blindfold?
I don't mean to barge in, ladies.
But...
I like the birds on your top.
Ok, she's like, don't...
Don't try.
She's like, don't...
I don't even want to hear it.
Yes, ma'am.
Sorry, ma'am.
Yay!
We made it.
Alright, time to find a light source.
It's right there.
Hello.
A minkie?
Pocky!
So sassy.
My money pouch.
What is that?
For us?
Oh boy.
Ok, good thing we've been stealing a lot, right?
Good thing we've been stealing a lot.
Sell me the minkie, actually.
How much is it?
75!
Where did all my money go?
I swear I had more money than 145 euros.
What?
How much for your books?
For books!
Holy moly.
I have to steal more.
Nice.
Thanks.
Hello.
Steep in thought.
I wish I could sell stuff.
Oh, sick.
An action figure.
Excuse me.
Who's got stuff that I can steal?
Do you steal?
Or rather...
There we go.
Ok.
Storyteller.
At least I'm rich in adventure points.
At least I...
Oh, what's Cut Man?
Oh, I forgot to read this one.
Oh, improved health bar regeneration efficiency.
Oh, hell yeah!
Nice.
I forgot how to do this, honestly.
Everything else?
Besides like Splinter...
Smash...
No.
Oh, what's this?
Take your books.
Improves the amount of health that is restored when applying bandages.
You're speaking my language, baby.
Wait.
Where is it?
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh, patch up.
Let's go?
Here, you guys listen to this story...
While I...
Eat a little bit more.
Oh...
What happened to the dog?
Oh, there's our dog!
Wait...
Wait, the dog spoke?
Wait, what?
I love the dog, it's just like, hey man.
Oh, I like these reactions.
Let's go for the dog?
Oh, easy.
Ah...
Thank you!
Thanks for the story!
I like the part when the dog talked.
Sassy.
Oh, this looks messy.
Wait a second.
I...
I recognize this door.
I recognize this type of door.
Let me in!
I wanna brawl!
I'm ready to...
The knuckle duster dead?
I'm ready to fight!
Let me in!
Wait, do I need to eat more fruit?
And grab.
Yoink!
Oh, good boy!
You can't pet the dogs in these games.
Did you see that monkey?
He sees nothing.
What do I...
What do I do with this?
Grandmother's chalice.
It was most likely stolen by Asma's monkey.
Okay.
Do I put it away?
What do I do with...
Who's grandma?
I'm such a creep.
What do I...
Who's grandma?
Give it back...
Where?
Who do I give it back to?
Grandma!
I think your monkey...
Grandma, I have your cup!
Don't...
Walk around town and listen.
I don't know.
Grandma...
Hi.
I'm looking for grandma.
But...
What are you talking about?
Indiana Jones, please.
What's happening?
Hold on, sorry.
I'll read that later.
Who are you talking to?
The curse of the Vatican is truly making us...
It's getting to us, everybody.
I fear that Indiana Jones will...
Oh, grandma!
Ooh!
Hamamashi recipe.
Fry the birds?
I got your cup, grandma.
You don't look like a grandma.
She said grandma, right?
Can I throw it?
Grandma.
Oh my god.
Other grandma?
Any other grandmas missing a cup?
Look at those chickens!
They are so brave.
I thought you were a person.
Hello?
Hi, grandma?
What am I taking a picture of?
Oh, the dog!
Good photo.
I want a good photo of you.
Come on.
Why isn't it...
Oh, here we go.
Nice.
He's like head bobbing.
Haha.
Where did I put the cup at?
By grandma's cup?
Where did you go?
Grandma's cup?
Oh no.
No, no, no.
Where did it go?
By the dog?
No, it's not.
Where did grandma's cup go?
No!
Oh my god, no.
I think...
Was it stolen?
Did it roll away?
Is this grandma's cup?
What is this?
A basketball?
Someone stole the cup.
It goes back to where it was.
Nice.
There's so many pictures to take of.
I guess it's...
I guess it's good though, because...
It makes it so that you can get lots of points.
Where was that monkey at?
Oh my god, here.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
I was worried.
Monkey stole my cup.
Which I stole from him.
Oh, yeah, that's me.
Hey.
Yeah?
Abandoned camp.
Wild dogs?
Be a good spy and tell me who this belongs to.
Does anybody know?
At least the dogs aren't so difficult to get rid of.
You just have to whip them.
Grandma, you.
You must be the grandma.
You lost your cup?
Look at that ugly old cup you're using.
This is your cup.
This is the cup that you...
Don't give me that look.
This is the cup you've been waiting all your life for.
Oh, she doesn't seem very impressed.
Okay, okay.
Gosh, you guys.
I don't want to run all around looking for grandma.
Grandma!
Grandma?
Oh my God, a goat.
Really?
I'll take a look.
What do you got?
Look at his jacket.
He looks so good.
Ah!
I dropped it for two seconds.
I just...
I feel like at this point...
Where?
Who said that?
Hold on.
I know a monkey.
I know where your cup is.
Where is it?
Hello, hello, hello.
I heard, I heard, I heard.
I heard.
Yes, yes.
I have it.
I have your damn grandma's chalice, please.
Who said that?
Who said the chalice?
Why would someone poison the dates?
That's such a good reference.
You?
Oh, there you go.
You're welcome.
Give me my money.
That's it?
Nothing happened?
She didn't give me anything?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna jump.
I actually took damage for that.
Hi, I'm gonna take your cookies.
Anything else?
Alright, let's go back to the site.
That's so mean!
Not even achieving nothing.
Nothing at all.
Okay.
Which way was that?
Over yonder.
Probably could have just looked in any direction for a giant sphinx.
Okay.
Alright.
Wow, there's a watchtower.
I didn't notice that before.
You think this place is...
No, I killed all of them.
I don't think anybody's back.
I think we're good.
Okay.
Other way.
Might be faster, but I see some cookies and I'll eat some fruit.
Oh, that is not fruit.
Take your prickly pears.
I wanna go tomb raiding with mint.
I think I wouldn't be a good tomb raider though.
I'm afraid of...
I'm afraid of the spiders.
Spiders.
Like all the spiderwebs and stuff.
I don't think I... I think I would chicken out.
I think I'd be baby about it.
Is there anything in here?
Nope, okay.
Parkour!
Oh my god, you scared me.
Hello.
Indy hates snakes and he still does it.
Yeah.
That's his job.
You know?
It's not my job to tomb raid.
Just saying.
This doesn't seem like a lot of light.
What do you mean to extinguish the flame?
What do you mean by that?
I've got you.
What?
Holy moly!
Um...
Well that...
Don't worry.
Yeah.
Uh...
Oh, pass through up here.
I have to climb.
Okay.
Climb down?
I like it spiky down there.
There's nothing down here.
I don't think...
They're here!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't see that at all.
Good thing my...
Yep.
Good thing my whip is magical.
Uh...
Yep.
Nice, nice.
What's over here?
I got you.
Strombo!
Hold on, I'm looking around too.
Hold on, I want to look around as well.
Oh.
What was that?
Who sneezed?
Who just sneezed?
Okay guys.
I'm gonna jump!
I don't know about that.
I would guess so, yeah.
You sneezed?
It was you?
Ancient relic.
The sussy.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Lots of writings.
Lots of stuff.
Okay.
Making our way through.
Fascinating.
This looks like an important fancy room.
It's a light puzzle!
I think.
I know.
I know I'm a week late, but thank you for the concert and making me and my friends cry from last cup of coffee.
Awesome.
What do you mean?
When are we getting official freak phantom glasses merch?
Never say never.
Well, you didn't say that, but...
I don't know when I can get around to it.
But it will happen.
I would like to make.
Thank you Panzer!
I'm glad you liked the concert!
Thank you.
Sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt you.
Alright, let's figure out this.
This puzzle.
What is this?
Can I move this?
It looks...
Well, I can move this.
This guy seems...
I think your big head is in the way, Gina.
I think you need to get out.
I love Doki Bird's meow meow song.
I found it.
I was like curious about it.
And I found a Japanese version of the song.
So I was like, what if I try singing it.
It's so cute.
Oh my god, finally.
He's getting...
Finally, he's like...
He's being just as sassy.
Oh my god, finally.
Yes, have a backbone, Indiana Jones.
Ok, actually...
This one probably goes to this.
If I had to wager.
If I had to guess.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna shine this right at...
Chat, right in your face.
You think like this it'll work?
Or does it have to be all four?
I don't think it's possible to be all four.
I am protected.
For now.
That didn't work.
I don't think these have to do with it either.
Is that not bright enough for you?
Is it not hitting it?
Maybe a hidden one.
Maybe.
There is something shining... Oh no.
That's...
It wouldn't be possible to do...
It is on it, right?
Yeah, it's on it, I think.
The bottom ones, these.
Do these even count?
It's not... It's not that...
That you need it to...
Oh, okay.
I understand.
No, please!
Okay, like this.
Apex679, thank you so much!
Okay...
And...
Nice!
I don't know if wonderful is the right word.
It's so scary!
What?
What if it's the mask?
What if it's like the mask in Lethal Company?
I don't know if this is going to end well.
Oh boy.
Madam.
Madam!
No,
the mask!
Sit on the haunted chair.
To be fair, I didn't think it was a throne.
He's so pissed off.
Isn't he so pissy all the time?
Good question.
Torch, torch.
There you go.
Yay!
Oh, that's not the right way.
Here.
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
Why are there so many?
I don't think scorpions are this big, right?
Hey, are we sure?
Where is the torch?
Oh, nice.
I'll take that.
And light it.
Nice.
Tig, go away!
Get out of here.
This wall looks weak.
Something heavy.
This?
I
found another door instead!
I found something.
I found...what do you mean you doubt it?
There are more weapons in here though.
Congratulations on 300k, Mito!
Thank you!
Ouch, ouch.
Nice.
Alright, now let me go get my torch.
Like, do something, Gina.
Gina.
Gina, I need you to go in front of me.
I need my torch, Gina.
Gina!
OK.
What do you want me to do in here?
Oh, my torch.
Or my lighter.
I guess I could have used my lighter to go get my torch back.
This game is so funny.
Oh my god.
Why are there so many scorpions?
Oh, we're back in here.
Nice.
Come on, Gina.
We're safe now.
Oh, no, just kidding.
This is another room.
Really loved all your streams and watching you play different games.
You really made my last two weeks by playing this and doing the USS Hornet stream.
Thank you so much.
I'm glad you like it.
Also, congrats on 3k milestone.
Thank you!
Alright.
We're gonna shine...
on here.
Or there.
OK.
How do we...
Interesting.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
What?
You're afraid of sunlight, Gina?
Come on.
Oh.
OK.
I'm trying.
I'm doing as much as I can.
You're broken.
We need...
Yeah.
We need to find the mirror.
Did you guys see one before?
Did you guys see a mirror at all anywhere?
In here?
Wait, we need... Oh, OK.
Man.
With such ease!
Are you sure?
I can throw it.
That was fast.
Thank you!
I'm not.
Wait, you got another one?
Oh my god.
Gina, you should have done it in there.
Gina!
OK.
Wait, hold on.
Let me get my stuff.
Where did I put my... Oh, there it is.
My torch.
Alright.
Poor Gina.
We could have done it as intended.
Alright, Gina.
Do your job.
Don't shine it at me.
Shine it at the thing.
Gina, I need you to tilt your body a little bit more.
Oh, OK.
It's working.
It's opening the door.
Gina?
Statue of Light puzzle complete!
I'm surprised it stayed open.
What's in there?
Gina, did you find any Among Us statues?
Guardians must have been highly regarded by the kings of ancient Egypt to be treated like this.
I feel like we can go in here, right?
I feel like we can go in there.
It's fine though.
Let's continue onwards.
What's this scary music for?
Why is it scary?
Why is it so scary?
What happened to your torch?
What?
Girl?
Here we go.
Another mirror?
She looks so scary when she crawls through.
You think?
How do you figure that?
Oh, the room where we came in!
I thought she meant the room where we sat in the big chair.
That looks like a sussy Among Us!
Beautiful.
This is the room that we were looking into!
So we did end up making it over.
Good job guys.
Sussy Ohio.
Alright.
Safely...
Carefully...
I think if I fell down there I'd be fine.
I think.
What are you doing?
What do you want?
I was just going to do what we did before.
Fine.
Where are the snakes?
We already had a single snake.
Singular snake.
Why?
Why can't I just do this again?
What do you mean go around?
Am I not seeing the correct...
Prove you'll be fine and fall?
Look at this guy.
Are you tough or something?
You're stuck in the floor?
Look at you guys, sinking into the floor.
Ok, hold on.
I should pay attention.
What are we doing here?
Does she want me to...
What do they eat down here?
Us, apparently.
That's why they're so hungry for us.
They're like, oh finally.
More food.
I'm trying to figure out where I go.
Do I swing to these?
She clearly wants you under the light.
Yeah, well...
There's nothing over here.
She said I'll try and distract them, but she's not doing a very good job.
I'm holding my own.
And I'm not sure where to go.
Oh my god.
Wait, hold on.
Ma'am, I would like to throw my...
Oh, hi.
Can I get my... Can I get my torch back, please?
My torch!
It's right there.
Oh, I got it.
I see it.
Come on.
It's so close.
If I grab it, I can throw it, you guys.
I'll throw it over there.
You know?
I just gotta get it.
I just gotta get my torch.
You're not doing a very good job, Gina.
Please, I'm down here now.
Come
on, it's right there.
It's like pixel.
I'm trying.
You all doubted me.
Are you OK?
Alright.
Watch my toesies.
I mean my fingies.
OK.
Over.
And...
Be gone, beasts!
Be gone!
Am I?
They respawn so fast.
Alright, I want out of here.
What's that sound?
Thanks so much.
I thought I heard voices.
I guess not.
These books?
Not books, but you know what I mean.
The stele!
Really?
A scene with a winged guardian-like figure watching over a ruler.
Stealing with a guardian motif.
She's like, yeah, don't disturb it.
He's like, belongs in a museum.
Come on, Gina.
OK, you can jump.
You got this, girl.
I'm hearing like a...
I don't know what I'm hearing.
Sand?
Something in here is going...
Do you guys hear it?
There's something in here that's like...
Something over here.
I hear it.
Every time I walk away.
Oh my god, that's my torch.
Where is she going?
Gina?
You guys heard that.
I'm afraid you're possessed.
I must kill you now.
Oh, we're back.
Or you can pull yourself up.
Like I had to do every single time.
Oh, it's so bright.
Ow, my eyes.
Love your butt.
What's wrong?
Indy, what's wrong?
Wally, happy birthday!
Hold on, I'll sing you happy birthday after this cutscene.
And I'm gonna eat some more dinner.
From the past.
Is this...?
Is this supposed to be Riz?
Archaeologist Riz?
What?
Yes, Rambo!
Sanctuary of the Guardians.
Oh man, oh wow, that's a lot of...
Okay, so we got one Sealy.
Hold on.
So that field work is technically done, but it also got us a Sealy, so we needed to do it anyway.
And then there's this...
Okay, these are the side quests, whatever, whatever.
Boss makes a dollar while I make a dime.
That's why I watch Minky on company time!
Thank you, Gordon Freeman.
Thank you for the superchat.
Hope you have a good day at work.
Oh, it says village dog.
I definitely thought it said hot dog.
Seat of Eternity.
Oh, that's right!
I'm actually kind of curious about this one.
Maybe we go check this one out.
Wait, where did we come out from?
Hello?
Okay.
These guys are still slackers!
Slackers, all of you!
Oh, this guy's got a dog.
You don't think the dog will notice, right?
Walking with Moxie!
Yeah, see?
I'm kind of curious about this area.
You don't think they'll notice all the people that are dead there, right?
Right?
And then for the other thing.
Well, we'll go over here and look what this is and then...
They said it was abandoned, right?
And then that there was a bunch of wild dogs.
We can get through the dogs.
I got my handy whip.
And then we'll see how close we are to some of the other Steelies.
Right there?
This is abandoned, but there's a train going to it.
How would it be abandoned if there are dogs?
Oh, here!
Wait, what are they chomping on?
Oh,
they're not afraid of this.
Down,
boy!
Down!
That's right.
Oh.
Oh, it's...
Oh my god.
I'm
gonna die to this dog.
Here I was appreciating your craft.
Take this.
I was appreciating what you've done to this person.
And you're floating.
Why?
How are you doing that?
What's in here?
I'm gonna go and be adventurous.
Apparently, there's nothing.
Oh, there is two adventure.
Can I...?
I have no idea where I am, but...
Wait, lower yourself a little Indy.
There you go.
Singular boi!
What did you say?
Sorry.
I can't believe on the same day I proposed to my girlfriend of 10 years!
Our girlfriend.
Congratulations!
What's this?
Open the sarcophagus?
Where am I?
Tomb journal?
What?
But I don't.
According to the local...
The tombs around here are haunted!
Or cursed.
Obviously complete and utter humbug.
Attaching a little nonsense ghost story to any artifact I find should double its value.
It's getting late and I thought I heard something outside.
Might not get much sleep tonight.
Oof.
Ripperoni.
Can I open the sarcophagus?
That was the quest or was it not?
Oh wow, he even left all his toys and everything.
Oh wait, my chat is frozen guys.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Give me a second.
Let me refresh you all.
One moment.
So I can see.
There we go.
Toys and doodads.
How do I open it?
Open the sarcophagus it said.
But it left no instruction.
Where am I?
Oh I'm at the seat of eternity I suppose.
Can I open it?
I need more jars.
Oh you are right.
I see, I see.
Oh I need a lot more jars.
Ok.
Interesting.
Is he the correct one?
No.
Does it matter?
Maybe.
That.
Ok.
Alright we got the correct one.
Well I guess I'll just leave and come back when it's...
When we get more.
This looks breakable doesn't it?
Oh yeah.
Oh that's extremely breakable.
Do we have any weapon?
This?
Nothing?
Really?
Thank you!
Can I get another birthday song from my friend Brandon?
His birthday was yesterday though.
Yeah I can!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Brandon!
From your friend Ichinobu!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
I'm gonna jump!
Alright.
I'm just gonna yeet the ancient Egyptian relic.
Oh good thing it's really sturdy.
And...
Nice.
I...
Wait...
I then...
Uh oh.
Oh there we go.
I thought it wouldn't allow me to whip it.
We're fine!
We stay here forever.
Okay.
This goes...
What about this?
Is that a human face?
Oh no no no no!
That's a human face.
Perfect.
It could have been a really ugly person is all I'm saying.
Could have been some guy with a really ugly mug.
Okay it doesn't have any secrets.
Another one!
Oh it was a minky!
I don't think that was a glitch.
Indy?
You okay buddy?
You wanna...
You wanna little...
You wanna prickly pear?
I'm scared.
Are we getting cursed?
They said it was haunted.
What was that?
I think it's just a sound effect.
So we have one last one left.
This one, but it's also mysterious.
Not sure what it is.
I'm scared.
What happened?
That was kinda freaky.
Oh my god.
Hello?
I'm just...
Like it's soccer balls?
I don't see where one more could be.
It's not that.
Is it this guy?
Maybe I destroy you.
Nope.
What could this be?
I don't see anymore breakable walls.
I thought maybe down there this one would be, but I don't think so.
That's just...
Look around?
What is there more?
And I'm just missing it?
I don't know.
A jar from the other room.
Oh it's around?
Really?
Just missing it for real?
What jar from the other room?
Oh my god.
What are these made of?
I think...
Ancient Egyptian technology is just something else.
Can I get a hint for anybody who knows?
It's inside.
Nope.
Nothing in there.
Swing across?
Check the other side of the hole.
Ah!
How mysterious.
And throw!
Good one Indy!
I'm surprised I made that.
Thank you guys.
I completely forgot about that other room.
Not even a skeleton.
It was completely empty.
What a waste.
Oh no, the dogs.
Come on.
The dogs are...
gone.
Ok.
Actually that works.
Even in the past, there is sus.
This is still just...
Alright, we are collecting the things of Ra.
The first one is right over here, so lucky it's pretty close.
And the others...
Oh wow, they are really scattered.
The idols of Ra.
Here?
Where I'm standing.
Oh, underneath where I'm standing.
I'll take you.
Spooky.
Oh, I have to set this on fire.
Very good.
The world's most powerful lighter.
I don't think we want to fall in there guys, but...
How do we open the door?
The archeologist is crying right now.
I am an archeologist!
I think right there.
Ok, let's see.
Alright, lower, lower, lower, lower.
Alright, nice.
Good job, Indy.
I hope everybody who does this has a whip.
Nice.
There is a lot of poor saps in there.
Not us though.
Nice.
We can use that for the previous puzzle.
They are all just right here.
Oh, we got it.
Steely!
A servant feeding a sacred crocodile for Sebek, the fertility god.
Steely.
Hi, Steely the Steely.
Fertility god, eh?
Oh my god, I didn't think I was going to make that for a second.
Alright.
I love these super foam, totally whatever piles of bricks.
Wait, 2 out of 4?
So I can go to whichever ones I want.
This one is right here, but it is kind of in a difficult location.
I don't know.
Do you think they will let us in?
I don't think it is the pyramid.
It is right in front of us.
Do we have to get all the Steelys?
I am still in my disguise.
I might be okay.
Hello everybody.
Where is the Steely?
Is it in here?
Shit!
That will do it.
That will do, Donkey.
That will do.
No one noticed.
All good.
Anyway, can we...
Do we have any secrets around here?
Any lock codes?
If I were a lock code, I would be on here.
0805.
Thank you.
Wait, locker?
No.
This one.
0805 Bingo!
A depiction of a bountiful harvest and the people reaping the rewards.
Steely!
Anyway...
No money?
I don't think...
I thought I heard...
I thought I heard a car pull up.
Is there anything else in here to Steely?
Anything?
You guys got...
any interesting...
stuff around?
Any money?
So I can buy more books?
Yeah, they are fine.
Probably, right?
Got any grapes?
There is nothing else in here.
That's so boring!
Lockbox, but you got to smash.
This guy?
What's over here?
Any money?
Any money, honey?
Any honey, money?
None.
Mint is now thinking, how many boxes did I skip?
Actually...
Well, I only noticed it for the first time in this stream.
I was like, oh yeah, huh?
There is a...
Ok, this thing is making me heavy.
Nevermind.
It's not making me any different.
Alright!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
I only noticed it for the first time in this stream.
So I was like, oh...
Are they all talking in there?
Having a grand old time.
If I go in there, they will boss me around.
Oh wait!
Oh!
We are fine, maybe.
Oh, it's a recreational area.
There is sand in my shoes.
What is in here?
Can I steal a uniform in here?
You think?
Probably, right?
A disguise.
Or... 5!
That's it!
What is this currency?
20.
5 is 5.
Robux.
5 Robux.
Yeah, exactly.
I think I can take on this whole camp.
Why hasn't she written anything yet?
Guess I better get going.
No, sounds good.
We'll come back.
Very bad.
Alright.
I thought he was bullying a guy.
Ok, let's see.
The other one...
We can go that way, we can go that way.
That's towards the village.
All the way that way.
Let's go towards the village, maybe.
Really?
Egypt would be pounds.
They were part of the British Empire at the time.
Makes sense.
I see.
What's in here?
What is this area?
Camels!
They're so cute.
They're so precious.
Look at that goofy smile.
One thing I still think about.
Have you guys ever seen that video of that camel laughing?
You're locked in here?
Requires discarded key.
Are you sure you're not going to kill me once I let you out?
Discarded key?
You think it's amongst the poop?
Oh my gosh, if you've never seen the video of the camel laughing... That's a lot!
Why do they keep it in a basket?
I hope the key is around here.
Where is it?
A fertilizer!
That's so true.
I didn't think about that.
You're right.
A key, a key.
I'm trying to help you out buddy, but I need you to like...
I'm trying to find it!
The key is around the house.
It is?
Yes!
The key is around the house or it's near?
You guys know where the key is.
Wait, I can take a photo.
Hold on guys, this is much more important.
Camels.
Say cheese!
Look at me, look at me!
Nice.
Beautiful animals.
And useful.
A key, a key.
If the key were in the poop, it would become Silent Hill 2.
Alright, come on Indiana Jones, time to reach your hand in the toilet.
I wish it would light up.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
You had it in your hand.
I'm not gonna lie, I totally thought the same thing.
I was like, I can just... I was like, stand back buddy!
I got you!
It is lit up?
Yeah, but I can't see if it is.
Oh, I like the sound of the wind in my ears.
Oh, sorry, this is not the correct mic for...
For ASMR wind blowing.
Can I have a hint?
Lots of trash around here.
Look up?
Is it that bird?
The
most powerful bird known to man.
Follow the gamer paint marks.
Gamer paint marks are made for me baby!
Let's see here.
A key to the locked building where a man is calling for help.
I'm gonna do it!
You're welcome.
Oh, nice.
And...
See, now that's a reward!
Now that's a reward!
Baby!
Nice!
Alright, that's not what I meant to do.
We are headed this way, I see it.
This way.
What is that guy squatting over there for?
Hello, I'm looking for a Steely.
Down here?
What happened?
Oops.
Steely?
Oh wait, here.
There we go.
Oh, we have to abandon you.
Alright.
Wait, did I have fall damage?
No, right?
Oh, the guy had fall damage.
Yeah, for sure.
Oh my god!
That's so awesome!
This is...Oh my god!
What a cool Steely!
This is the best one!
A giant sized figure walking among smaller men, perhaps symbolizing the half god status of a pharaoh.
Or just that there's giants.
Now what?
Bring the Steely.
Ok, we gotta bring the Steely's back.
What if I wanted to get the other Steely's?
Alright.
I'm keeping this, so...
Fire!
Wait, timber!
Nice.
Four!
So dramatic, Indy.
Where did my weapon go?
Oh, there it is.
My trusty...trusty steed.
Hello!
Take your...
Cookies.
Move your feet please!
No!
I want your cookies!
Give me your cookies!
No!
Oh my god.
Nobody heard anything, right?
Anyway...
You're a heavy guy.
Hold on.
Give me a bit of a...
Ok, there we go.
Nice.
And...drop.
Oh wait.
How do I drop?
Maybe backwards.
And drop.
Raiders?
Wait, I'm not getting any raid notifications.
Hello!
Thank you guys!
Sorry, I'm not getting any notifications.
Ok, now I can finally take his cookies.
Welcome!
I had a dream you were in a video game in a section called Mince Hints.
But all your hints were unsettling, like saying how the player could breathe after being buried alive.
Oh, how long a player could breathe after being buried alive.
Sounds like some useful hints, huh?
I wouldn't want to know how long I could breathe...
...after being buried alive.
Ducky, thanks for the gift!
I just killed a man!
Oh, and I killed my...
I killed my club!
Alright.
Oh, you gotta go this way anyway.
You think I can climb up this hill?
Only one way to try.
Half the fun is not knowing.
True.
What's down there?
I don't know.
I'm kind of scared to look.
I'm gonna go around.
Also, I couldn't get it open.
Carzy!
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Think I should turn back?
Oh.
Okay.
I got it.
Alright.
You're fine, Indy.
Don't worry.
It's an interesting way to do invisible walls.
Gosh, what a nice stroll.
What's in here?
Sphinx Temple Ruins.
Someone's talking.
And I'm also gonna steal their persimmons.
Nice.
I'm the persimmon stealer.
Oh, hi!
Look at all these nice boxes to hide behind.
Maybe I shouldn't have gone in here.
Is this also a guy that will catch me?
Oh God, I'm just gonna leave in here.
Let's just leave.
Oh gosh.
We're going back to the village.
Are all these slackers still...
There's new guys!
They got rid of the slackers!
There's actual people there!
Dang.
We could...
What is it?
Worker's area?
No, not the village.
Where am I going?
The worker's area!
Hello.
Not impressive.
I'm gonna go.
I can kill these guys again.
What?
There's only two of them.
There's only two of you.
And one of me.
Where was he?
Hello.
Ellenbrin.
I can take the rest of it.
Anyway, let's go deliver these.
And as cutscene happens...
I eat dinner.
Hello.
I delivered them to you.
Bring the steelies.
I got them.
Your steelies.
Your steelies?
Oh, here.
Giant steely.
Harvest steely.
Protector steely.
Sub-ex steely.
You're welcome.
Bananas.
What if they want to take the bananas though?
Alright.
Don't mention it.
Delivery boy.
Over here?
I have...
Is that what those bananas are too then?
Okay.
Alright.
Thanks.
Yeah, you better.
Got it.
Work passes obtained from the museum.
Nice.
Alright, let's go deliver these.
I have this for you.
You want them here?
She is very specific.
Alright, Dame Duval.
What have you got?
Have you heard of the tunnels underneath Giza?
There have been some findings, but...
mostly hypothetical.
Until now.
Are these the tunnels?
Some of them, yes.
Now these are unconfirmed from a highly speculative paper regarding the existence of a burial chamber.
Much like the Osirian Miss Murray and Sir Petrie found in 1903.
But, I believe that one of my agents has found an entrance right here that leads straight into the Nazi compound.
Now, this is my proposal.
I do.
Once inside the dig site, act quickly.
Find the tunnel that leads into the camp before you are discovered.
Got it.
This guy is literally that meme of people with blue eyes.
Ok, find the tunnel entrance.
Take some persimmons.
Marked with red paint.
Alright, we gotta be quick.
Indy, be fast.
Indy, be quick.
Indy, beat the guards up with a stick.
Excuse me.
I'm looking for...
wares and things to steal and eat.
How's my... actually...
You know what, my...
My stamina?
We could use some more.
I can take these last two.
I appreciate it.
I'm very greedy, thank you.
Anyways.
Yep.
Alright, red.
Red, red, red paint.
No?
Any red paint?
Any red paint over here?
Hello?
Oh!
I think I found it.
And they even left us a Minecraft.
What?
Oh my God!
You're not afraid of tight spaces, are you?
That's so good.
Oh, ok everybody.
Let's...
Let's all, you know, use all the strength.
Everything.
That's a mummy!
Oh my God, that's a mummy!
Oh, dang.
Mummy!
Mummy.
Sorry, mummy.
Yikes.
Ok, hold on.
Oh, a headless mummy!
Wow!
Do we not care about these mummies?
Are these not huge archeological feats?
Like, what is this?
Oh, ok.
Hey!
Why does she sound like that?
Ma'am?
Why is it so spooky in here?
I thought these were steelies for a second.
These look like we need to put stuff on top of them.
And this?
Oh, my eyes.
Normal mummy, not cat mummy, so no care.
I guess that's fair.
Oh, our cat mummy was not even a cat mummy at all.
Oh, my God.
Jeez Louise!
Oh, that's going to be us.
Yeah, a dead body.
Um,
what do you mean by that?
Something is moving on the floor.
What do you mean by that?
I'm going to throw this?
Oh, it's these guys!
Ok, not very far apparently.
Where did all these guys come from?
Chill, chill, chill.
Ok.
And then I think I...Oh, my God.
If I drop it now...
Will they stay away?
Ok, they do.
Ok, nice.
And throw!
And take you!
And...
I'm trying!
You think I'm just like playing around here?
Ma'am!
Don't, don't, don't, don't play with me.
Drop!
And...
Run.
Ok.
So I can kind of create like a little pathway.
Well, actually...
Yeah, I'm trying.
I'm scared.
They don't seem to like have...
They don't seem to be so afraid of the torches when they are on the ground.
Oh...
Go away, go away.
Alright.
Throw!
At least they go away for like a little bit.
And...
Throw!
Ok.
Ok, I'm gonna drop it.
Run!
I'm trying!
Oh my god.
Yeah, go, go!
Get, get!
Be gone!
Oh, I'm running out of stamina.
I think if I put it here...
I might be ok.
Ok, there you go.
Now what?
Nice.
Where, where are we going?
Good.
I guess this opened up too.
Oh, this is where we are going.
Good job.
Ok, we can go there.
And that's it.
We can't go anywhere else.
Now, we know that there...
How do we know that this leads to outdoors?
Oh.
Alright, Gina.
Take down the flag.
That, oh, all the way over there?
Oh no, ok, right there.
Alright, let's go, let's get it down.
Yeah.
And if we find any guys, just...
Just beat them up.
Wait, where?
Right there, ok.
How do we get over there?
Oh my god, there's like, I hear voices everywhere.
Oh my gosh, there's...
Oh, this place is every...
Oh, no!
Where are you going, Gina?
Oh.
Nobody notices us, right?
Oh, someone did.
Kind of.
Maybe.
Might be fine.
I'm gonna eat some fruit.
So I can replenish my...
Stamina.
A prickly pear.
Ok.
Oh, perfect.
That's what I was looking for.
Alright, good.
Someone notice me?
Nah.
Gina, take this.
Gina, take...
The other...
Take the other one.
Take the other...
Take the other shovel.
No?
Ok.
Hi Melvin, thank you for a month.
Thank you.
I got him.
Anyway.
They're probably fine.
But down.
For a while.
Maybe a long while.
Who knows.
Anyway.
Alright, onwards.
Up there.
We gotta take the flag.
Oh my gosh, I love a good game of capture the flag, baby.
Oh, hello.
Oh, is he the medic?
Can I take your bandages?
Bandage.
Yeah.
What are you doing, Gina?
Oh shit.
Guys, this might be...
We might be in trouble.
Nah, he's gonna turn around.
He's gonna turn around.
Yeah, see?
Is she ok?
Oh my god, Gina, you scared me so bad.
What do I do here?
Army!
What just happened?
What's happening?
Ok.
I don't know yet.
Yeah, exactly.
Everybody should be running towards that direction.
There should be no one around.
What's this?
Oh, those are...
Dynamite?
Hello?
I kinda want it though.
Why are you acting so casual?
Something just blew up in your...
In your place!
Oh, he said...
Shotgun!
Someone save me?
Every time I hear that...
I'm like, did someone save me?
Oh, yes they did.
Goodbye.
Thanks.
I will have to kill you though.
Well, not kill.
You know.
I will have to...
Can I take any more cookie?
Give me your cookies.
Oh, item limit reached?
Really?
Oh shit, this guy knows how to fight.
It's ok.
So do I.
Oh!
There is a guy right there?
Oh my god.
Gino, where are you going?
I can't stand her.
I'm gonna use a bandage real quick.
I'm scared of...
I'm scared of death.
I've got hands.
That's not an important item?
Ok.
I tried using it for security.
I don't want them to hear me.
God.
I could hide their bodies, but you know...
Oh!
They just don't stop coming, and they don't stop coming, and they don't stop coming, and they don't stop coming!
Oh my god Gino, you scared me.
Get out of the way!
They don't stop coming, and they don't stop coming!
I guess we can just... It says go up over this way, but I feel like we're...
You know, we'll just go up over this way.
Bandage.
Uh oh, we're getting spotted by something, someone, somewhere.
Where?
Whomst?
I think I was in the correct spot.
Oh, show yourself?
I'm here?
Who's seeing me?
Whomst.
Oh, that guy over there.
Wow, these guys have such... Oh, I was gonna say he has such eagle eyes, but...
He actually just...
I wanna say it's a rat?
Oh my god.
He took him out.
The NPCs in this game are so stupid.
They wish they could be Metal Gear.
What the hell?
No way.
I can do anything and they'll be like... Literally just the wind.
I love this game.
This is if I were good at Metal Gear.
Stealth is just, you know...
Whatever.
Who?
Who's mad at me?
I don't know.
Whatever.
But if I use that... If I use this...
I think there's people in here, right?
Oh yeah.
What the fuck?
Hi.
Oh wow.
Didn't even notice.
That's so great.
Gina, he's gonna see you.
Gina, he's gonna... Oh shit.
Oh, I'm trying.
Yeah, double team him.
And take their money.
Good job everybody.
Good job team.
Eat the melon bread.
Take the melon bread.
Oh my god, what did I get now?
Bread is life.
This is so silly.
I did say this earlier.
I was just wanting to look around a little bit before...
Before we grabbed it.
Thank you for writing to me regarding your desire for an interview.
Well, your ideas certainly sound interesting for lack of a better word.
Do you really consider yourself the world's greatest archaeologist?
I am an extremely busy journalist and have no time for writing puff pieces for anyone.
Not even Indiana Jones himself.
Speaking of which, why do you insist on calling Dr. Jones a fraud?
I can name a multitude of his most important finds.
Even can barely count yours on one hand.
Even if two of my fingers had been severed.
Okay Gina, please.
Anyway, thank you for your proposal, but I must respectfully decline.
Damn.
Volcano?
I don't... I don't recall who that's supposed to reference.
Damn, that's such a good insult.
I would be able to count on one hand, even if two fingers were severed.
Like, damn!
Wait, there's still a guy there?
I think more than the Dreamlands, Indiana Jones.
This is where we're supposed to be, right?
Find Vos' office.
I'm guessing it's down here.
Alright, I knew it.
How does he get to it?
I like your hat and whip, Mito.
Thank you!
Let's... okay.
Okay.
What's this?
Ooh.
Battleship Clements disappeared off the coast of Peru.
Missing all crew members.
Last communication from ship received May 2nd.
0012, Berlin time.
The sun is so bright!
Has the Titanic happened yet?
Yeah, wait, Titanic was...
Yeah, 1912.
Okay, I was thinking that, but I couldn't quite remember if it was right.
I knew it was before World War II.
Details surrounding disappearance withheld from this telegram.
Ship part of classified expeditionary operation.
Wow, I can't believe I remember that though.
I can't believe I remember that!
1912.
What's this?
Letter.
Affirmation letter.
Oh god.
Dear...
I read your report about the events in Peru.
Is it true?
It is true.
We have lost a very valuable battleship, but the results of the experiment instills hope that it is worth even more.
These are degenerate times.
Degenerate times.
It's pronounced...
Forehead.
And it is our duty to drag the world into an age of purity.
Do not weaken, Vos.
If Operation Great Circle is the triumph you have promised, our final success is assured.
I look forward to your next report.
It's that guy!
The interpretation of dreams.
Oh my gosh!
It's Sigmund Freud.
Sigmund Freud's book about his theory of unconsciousness and how it's represented in dreams.
First published in 1899, it was later banned in Germany when Hitler rose to power.
Minto, you gotta memorize how to say degenerate times in German.
Say it to Kiwawa next.
She'd be like, where did you learn that?
Um...
I don't think I could tell her where I learned it from.
I don't think I could tell her.
She'd be like, who did you learn that from?
This guy is poor.
He's got a little sketch.
Symbols rubbing!
Sorry, I'm trying to look for all the stuff before we get the cutscene.
Genesis chapter.
Oh, this is a lot of text.
Wow, this is a lot of text.
The Idol of Ra.
Journal?
Oh my god, we're reading his...
Okay, if you're gonna talk that loud, shut the door man, please.
We're reading her diary?
Aww...
The symbols with the dots and the lines remind me of...
So there was this one...
Eroge I played...
Where...
It's one of those games where you like...
Where you uncover the picture behind it.
And you would connect dots in certain ways.
You only had a certain amount of moves and you would connect the dots in certain ways.
So that they would connect and then get rid of a piece of the picture.
So you could see underneath.
Money!
I think that's everything and then we can take the key and I think then we'll be good.
Everybody's doing every little tiny ant.
The worlds in this...
It's actually kind of fun that it's so open world.
You know, like I didn't expect this game to be...
Like, oh you can really just travel anywhere.
Like it's actually really nice.
I don't remember the name of it.
It had...
Nuns.
That's all I can remember.
I can't remember it.
If I remember it...
I'll tell you guys.
I don't gatekeep.
Opens the attic of the Nazi detention and interrogation center.
You don't think I'm gonna get demonetized from this, do you?
What?
A train?
Okay.
That's why I try to say nachos instead.
What's happening?
Boss arriving.
Where is he?
Where?
I'm trying to get a good picture of him.
Where is he?
Why are they all gathered around?
Is that him?
No.
Where are you?
Where is he?
Where?
Oh there he is!
There he is!
He's so small.
I was just taking pictures of these guys.
Okay, okay.
He's like...
Okay, he's like far, far away though girl.
We're gonna have to get all the way over there.
Don't look at me like that!
No, my weapon.
Oh, it only has one left.
I hear a guy in here complaining.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's not go down there.
Oh, we're down there.
Oh god.
Okay.
Gina.
Gina, we need a good plan.
Girl.
I'm just gonna take this and their money.
While I can.
Yeah, good thing I didn't stop to read that.
Requires a hallmarked key.
Interesting, where can we get that?
I mean there is a...
What is in there?
Oh what is that?
What is that?
It's glowing!
There is also here.
The save, nice.
Oh, we can leave through here.
Awesome.
I think we can leave through here.
Vermark.
Mark.
Can we leave through here?
The door is open, but we'll be far away from him.
Let's try going over this way.
Little bit more of a shortcut.
Probably, maybe.
Oh, perfect.
Oh, we're so good at this game.
Okay, that's not a person, sorry.
I hear a lot of people yelling.
Is everybody not concerned about the explosion that happened?
We're just gonna forget that that happened.
Vos is back, so we're just like, yeah, whatever.
I'm looking for...
For some sort of weapon.
That's a truck, Minto.
I know, but it looked like a person!
For a second, it looked like a person.
Gina, are you okay?
Gina girly.
Oh, here we go.
Perfect.
And some cookies.
That I can't take.
Gina!
Okay, don't come walking up like nothing happened, okay?
It's over there, right?
Yeah.
Look, she's hiding.
Maybe she's good at this.
We're sneaking?
Oh.
Wait, this is super stealthy.
Never mind.
My fat ass can't reach.
Gina, don't go that way.
I know!
Oh my god.
Gina.
Don't get caught.
Please.
Please, Gina.
Don't get caught.
Oh my god, Gina.
Gina.
Gina, you're scaring me.
I can't get around here.
That sucks.
That noise.
I didn't know he was still there.
We're fine.
Oh, they had no weapons?
They had a gun.
But I don't want to use a gun.
I feel it will be too loud.
And really start alerting people, you know?
I just brushed him.
Oh, that's a weapon.
And... I can't have... Oh, wait.
Maybe I can eat some fruit.
And steal your fruit.
Prickly pear.
Who's checking me out?
Over this way.
That guy right there?
No way.
Hide?
I think we're good, Gina.
Don't worry about it.
Just take all their money.
He's checking his list.
Who's checking me out?
Oh my god.
Duck, duck, duck, duck.
There it is.
Wait, is this a... Oh, that's a flute.
I don't think it's very effective, probably.
I'm gonna throw this over yonder.
Damn it.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
He's a big guy.
Oh, he's big.
Where's your... Not your body.
Where's your...
Oh no!
Oh, he dodges.
Oh, they're too good.
They're too good.
Oh my god.
Oh, there it is.
Your club.
Thank you.
Hold on, Gina.
I might need to heal.
Gina, I need to heal.
Hold on for me.
Gosh.
Now I need the bread.
Why aren't they using the guns?
Luckily, they don't have bullets on their guns.
I know, right?
Gosh.
We will be stabbed a hundred times over.
Wait, where'd my...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright, perfect.
And we're going...
That way.
Hi, Gina.
Let's try... Distracting the guards.
Oh, wait.
I already...
Oh, shit.
There's not another bottle in here?
There was just one?
Only one?
Throw the loot.
Oh, wait.
I can grab this again.
There we go.
Alright, let's throw this bottle.
Oh, gosh.
You scared me, Gina.
Don't scare me like that.
I don't think they cared.
What's great is if you shoot them, they don't really care all that much.
Like, what I mean is...
Move!
Is they...
They don't say like, oh, we gotta alert the whole camp.
You know what I mean?
Where did I put my club?
Oh, I messed up, Gina.
Move.
I gotta go find it.
Well, at least put the shovel in here.
Alright.
Yeah, there's like no alarms that goes off and signals everyone.
That's what I was trying to say.
Yeah, they just don't care when you shoot them.
Yeah, you know.
Whatever.
They don't care.
I don't care.
What else is in here?
Money.
I love looting.
Gina!
Gina, I can use your help!
I can use your help!
Thank you.
Yeah, she can take a few hits.
Good job, Gina.
You took a few hits for me.
Nice.
Alright, that's where we're supposed to go in there, right?
Yep.
I don't know why it's telling us to go up there first, but...
I'm just not gonna listen to that and I'm gonna go through the front door.
That seems like a better idea.
Opens elsewhere?
Okay.
Like up there?
Why do I need to go up there?
What was the point?
Wait, this is the same way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Look at him.
He's retreating!
Uh-oh.
Where?
No, this in here.
Come on, Gina!
Come on!
Come on, come on.
Just leave.
Just get out of here.
Stealth!
Damn, I was gonna say, how is he still up?
Now I have a stick, but only...
He literally put his gun away.
We got him.
Why did you put your gun away?
Alright, let's go up here.
He likes a fair fight.
And there will keep being enemies down, or allies down.
As long as I'm here.
It is September and after the battle of Abourkir Bay.
Our forces have surrendered to the British.
We have but a year to leave Egypt.
I hope we can transport our most valuable of items home.
Like the Rosetta Stone.
I think we're
fine.
Sorry, I got paranoid that someone was gonna come up the stairs.
Okay, let's keep going up.
Is this the wrong way?
Oh, there he is!
We'll just ignore him.
From here, I think?
There
we go!
I think that was the guys downstairs.
Oh, we put our outfit on!
Indie time.
Okay, got lots of bottles.
I could probably heal.
Hit the strong box?
Wait, where?
Oh no, I don't think it was, because it didn't turn red.
I don't think it was a strong box.
Because the little...
The little white dot in the middle, what's it called?
It turned red.
It opens from the other side.
How do we get downstairs?
Oh, here.
I'm literally pulling up the floorboards.
Okay,
back to eating dinner.
Why is the music so loud?
Is he gonna get killed?
Okay.
Why is this a good cutscene?
The most German monkey sounds I've ever heard.
How do you want to make up for it?
Do you hope that the solution will give you another chance?
Oops.
Return to monkey.
Hi!
Hey!
This is so sad.
I like his poofy pants.
Oh!
Where's the other guy?
Did we fall on top of him?
Maybe we should watch him too.
Do you think he's dead?
Oh!
It won't let me shoot him!
That's so messed up.
Okay, I think this might have a time limit, so...
Dependent.
No way, time paradox real.
I know, don't tell me it's about a woman, yes?
What?
It is always about a woman, isn't it?
I mean is he wrong though?
No.
I could fix him, I don't know.
What?
The guys are still yelling at him.
How low are we crouching if we look like that when we crouch?
And on his knees he looks like that.
Okay, let's examine.
I'm getting a picture.
We didn't debug him!
Stop giving him clues, Cindy!
This is far beyond your understanding, Dr. Jones.
Stop talking!
Oh, maybe he already knows.
Okay, so he knows.
Okay, he knows.
Don't insult a nerd, they will out-nerd you.
Yeah!
Do it anyway!
Okay.
He deserves it, probably.
See, I told you we should have shot him!
I told you!
The game!
What a lover!
Get your nose broken, Voss.
Not Huey, Emmerich.
Oh my god!
Maybe he is a real monkey!
Monkey!
Did he shoot the painting?
Oh girl!
Oh my god, no!
No way!
Is this Looney Tunes?
Do me a favor, my friend.
Go to a dentist.
Oh my god!
Another tunnel?
Okay, let's go.
I wish I could fight everyone.
I want to fight the whole world.
Fists are blazing.
I want to...I want to have a fight club where everyone just comes and fights me.
Okay, we are going this way.
Wisp fight club win.
Now.
Wow!
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Go?
I'm trying to get over?
Run!
Oh my god!
You do?
I don't see anybody!
Is that her?
I sure hope so.
Into the tunnel!
That was so fun!
Oh my god.
Are you alright?
I think half of her is in the ground.
I don't know where to go.
You've kind of...okay, let me follow you.
Oh, there we go.
I was a little lost.
I'm just a slithery snake.
Very nutty buddy game.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are you sure about that?
What do you mean?
If it's not the...you said exit tunnel.
Thank you.
If it's an exit tunnel...
It's not an exit tunnel.
This would also be technically an exit tunnel.
Right?
If there's an exit.
I'm exploring.
I'm just trying to find some cool stuff.
Nobody lets me ever do what I want to do.
I'm sick of being Indiana Jones.
Okay.
Where are we?
Why are all the lights so bright all the time?
Okay.
Doesn't seem like there's much of anything else.
John!
Thank you so much for the loot.
Thank you so much.
Harrison Ford can do whatever he wants to me.
Brian!
Down boy, down!
Oh.
This way?
Oh, wrong thing.
Here we go.
Oh my gosh, sorry guys.
I'm always pressing the wrong buttons.
In here, right?
This is the way...
This way?
Is that what you're talking about?
This way, right?
Wow!
A little snake!
Someone put their snake in the Egypt hole.
Danger noodle.
He's so cute.
I love snakes.
The Guardians?
It's the Nephilim Order.
The Nephilim Order working with the ancient Egyptians thousands of years before the rise of the Christian Church.
Only the Guardians carry the key to unlock the enigma...
of Haramaket.
Horus of the Horizon.
Revered in the form of...
The Sphinx!
And opened the way into the Safehold.
Must be a reference to the Dream Stele.
This is what Vos has been looking for.
How to unlock the Dream Stele.
The Dream Stele.
Not unlock.
Solve.
It's not a physical key.
It's the tattoo.
Tattoo?
The Dream Stele is encrypted.
The tattoo on the Nephilim.
The Guardians.
Must be the decoding key to solving the cipher.
And it's been under Vos' nose the entire time.
Now I just need to pay a visit to the Sphinx.
We were just there.
Ok.
Oh my God.
Please, my eyes.
Ok.
Am I going the right way, Dame Noire?
Yes.
Yes?
Where is the...
Let's start digging.
Wait.
Where is the wall weak?
Over here?
Over...
Where?
Over there.
Over here.
Here?
Where is the weak wall?
I see it.
Sorry.
She is blind.
I play Minecraft.
Blind Minto.
Pocket sand.
Get pocket sanded.
You're welcome.
Which one?
I know what you are.
That's my birthday.
Pika!
I think you have the cutest model in Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas!
Happy birthday, Pika!
Thank you!
I hope you have a great day!
Oh wow, we really just shoved him in there.
Nice.
Who sneezed?
There we go.
And for you, mister?
A little whack-a-roo.
If only I could get to you.
Alright, this game is very nice about giving lots of...
Oh, perfect.
Lots of bandages and such.
We could probably go back to the...
What's in here?
Probably go back to the village and grab some...
What?
Actual mine.
Grab some stuff from the store.
I think I have enough money.
Maybe some of the books.
Hello!
Perfect!
The tower has got stuff.
Ok, cool.
Might want to check the tower before leaving.
Oh, tower.
Thank you guys.
We are about to leave Giza?
We are done here?
I don't have the key!
I never got the key!
Is that a uniform?
The key is inside.
Ok, wait.
Hold on.
What's my...
Yeah, we can eat these.
Take
that.
How do I get up there?
Gotta do some parkour, baby!
Ok, hold on.
Gotta figure out how to get up there.
Do I see anywhere that I can...
What?
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I don't want to walk all the way down there.
Congrats on 300k.
Thank you!
Appreciate it.
Gesundheit.
How fitting.
Many are German today.
Look on the other side.
Wait.
The other side of the building.
Where does the paint go to?
Hold on.
Maybe I can circle around the other side.
There we go.
Nice.
Are any of these windows open?
Any of them.
Any of these windows open?
None of them.
None of them so far.
I'll wait for him to turn the rack around.
Ok, buddy.
That's what that...
Are you in your underwear?
Stop blocking.
Yeah.
Dummy.
I wish blocking didn't use stamina.
Can I go down?
Wait.
What is this?
Bullets.
Got a new weapon.
You can charge a punch if you can break their block.
And then this is the key, right?
Nope.
It's a money baby.
Let's go.
Is that why you were naked?
You literally were...
What's this?
Naughty.
Ok.
I'm going to change now.
Oh wait.
This will do.
But it doesn't have the key in here.
I guess that's fine.
We'll just unlock it from...
Oh, I did get the key.
Oh, it came with a uniform.
I can go back and...
Alright.
Hello.
What did you say?
Oh, the person wanted more stuff, right?
Alright.
Inspect the dreams daily.
What other things we got in here before we head out?
We did all the field work.
Kinda crazy.
But there is so much.
I feel like I haven't even touched everything in this.
Like there is the meteorologist station I barely looked at.
Anything past that I barely looked at.
The vehicle store.
There is so much to explore in this game.
It's insane.
There is
one in the city.
A field work in the city.
Like I don't plan on doing some of the side quests like the fight club, stuff like that, whatever, whatever, but...
Chilling.
Sola!
Where is that guy?
Maybe they couldn't find a good voice actor.
I don't know.
Or maybe they were just like, you know, it's indie but we'll do new characters.
Sola.
Like we can go in there and we can fight.
Rosie, thank you!
First time I'm catching you streaming your model design.
It's so lovely.
I call you my human based VTuber discovery of 2024 as an AI VTuber guy.
She's very cute.
I'm also a fan.
Are there many other AI VTubers I wonder?
I haven't heard of any others.
Quite honestly.
Parked car.
Come on.
Why is this so difficult?
Well, some guy is also missing a basket.
Am I AI?
Yeah.
Ask me anything.
I'll give you an answer.
The others are small.
Oh, I see, I see.
I've seen like two.
Okay, so yeah, the Sphinx is where we got the...
What's your favorite movie?
My favorite movie...
My favorite movie is...
The tape your mom and I made last night.
Got'em.
Don't frowny face!
Minto, I'm sorry that you didn't win Miss VTuber.
But as a consolation, will you accept this great circle from me and be my Mrs. VTuber?
Oh my god.
Wow, that was pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie.
That was pretty good.
I...
You know, for the... I didn't talk really about the VTuber awards or anything like that.
But, you know, just being nominated for anything honestly made me feel...
Feel good, so don't feel bad.
And also my Oshi won, so...
A win for my Oshi is a win for me.
I even voted for Kiara, so...
So honestly, I'm super duper... I'm super duper happy.
Mhmm.
Like I didn't walk around down here at all.
I think that guy we gotta avoid though.
Bless you.
Like in here?
There's all this stuff we have.
What is this?
I can't read.
Let me in.
Record...
Haunted... Haunted Crypt Key?
How?
I also knew that I didn't win because I was talking to Doki and she was like, oh yeah, did Filian contact you about recording any videos?
And I was just like... She had asked me about something, but...
And I was... But it wasn't like about a...
About like a award winning video.
So Doki was just like, oh yeah, then you didn't win.
I was like, oh, okay.
So, you know, I get...
Oh?
I guess... I guess if you... I guess that's how you kind of know.
It's like a little inside secret, I guess.
Thanks.
That's why you ask for one from everyone.
I was thinking that too.
I was like, don't... Don't post award shows.
Just ask everybody for one to avoid that kind of like...
That kind of, oh see, yeah, we haven't been here at all.
That kind of situation.
But wait, or have we?
Oh, we took the tunnels.
No, we have not been here.
ASMR, wind sound.
Tent on the other side for a quest.
Other side.
Like over there?
That other side?
What's up here?
I really feel like I'm in Egypt.
The only thing about this game is I know there's fast travel, but it like feels so long.
I wish there was like... I wish I could like ride a camel or a horse or something to get around.
Takes so long to get anywhere.
Am I just walking?
I miss D-horse.
Yeah, we need a D-horse.
Do you ever go to Egypt for real?
I would love to.
But...
It's a little scary.
It's a little scary right now.
In D-horse.
Comic book.
Horror tales number two.
Oh yeah.
Oh, is that a djinn?
Oh yeah, Professor Grobbin and the Desert Djinn.
I know.
I'm also gonna rob you guys.
Can I fast travel?
Yeah, I would want to do more exploring if I could get around more quickly.
Otherwise like... I know you can run, but I run out of stamina so fast.
I run out of stamina so easily.
And I want to explore, but I'm like...
That's my... Probably my main complaint with the game so far.
I should get out of here.
I'm in trouble.
Punch him!
Let's leave.
Let's go.
Okay, I'm gonna confirm his identity.
This is a whole side quest area anyway?
Okay.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Everybody is always sneezing.
I'm worried about these guys.
About this whole universe, this whole world.
Why is everybody so sick?
Why?
Blue eyed person meme, real.
Jumbo Lasso.
Heavyweight enemies can be whip pulled into a grab?
Yeah, I will.
And I'm gonna learn it right now.
That sounds awesome.
Books.
It's not exploration.
No, that's the Giza relics.
Jumbo Lasso.
I have plenty of points.
I have 1600 now.
I have so many points.
I feel like I'm not...
I feel like I'm exploring a lot, but...
I'm getting more points than I get of books.
I feel like I explore a lot though.
Maybe not optimized exploration, but...
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
I guess I'll walk home in the desert.
Riches flowing.
Where are we?
What's over here?
I just wanna look around.
Oh, this is the meteorological area, isn't it?
Right here.
Weather station.
What?
It's a perfect...
There.
Hello.
Excuse me.
What's this?
Radio frequency.
What do you mean?
Are you okay?
What's wrong?
Take the money.
Mystery note.
Different types of clouds?
Cute.
And handwriting.
I don't know if you know, but you can push enemies over ledges with right stick.
And it's my favorite take down.
Really?
I didn't know that.
Mystery note.
Okay.
New mystery.
Cloud Atlas.
Okay, so this seems like a...
Hello.
Wait, hold on.
What is Cloud Atlas?
Oh, it's just like a...
So I just figured it out and then I probably can open this.
I imagine.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Alright, let's figure this out.
Let's figure this out, guys.
Let's figure this out.
Not that bad!
Okay, little chest quest.
Yeah, exactly.
We can get some goods and stuff in here.
Okay, inspect.
So...
Clear skies...
And
Cirrus...
Okay.
Call?
Wait, I'm confused.
1310.
Are these dates?
Like, October 13th, October... No, that wouldn't make sense.
Learn your clouds.
I know, I know, I know Cumulonimbus.
I know Cirrus.
I know...
I know Cumulonimbus because they're my favorite clouds because they're summer clouds!
I know Cirrus Stratus clouds.
I know Stratus clouds.
I don't know Nimbo Stratus clouds.
I don't know Stratoculimbus clouds.
I know clouds!
I don't understand this though.
I don't understand this at all.
Maybe I should come back here as a tourist?
No, help!
Dates equals numbers.
So 10, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14...
And then 15, 16 were clear skies...
And Cirrus clouds, maybe.
Or
is it... Hold on.
13, 14...
13, 14, 9, 16...
Do you have any details on when your waifu cup becomes available from gamer shops?
I want to pump with my Yoshi.
We're working on one other thing with the drop, so...
I think once that becomes finalized, which might be a minute.
13, 9, 16, 10 is Cirrus Stratus Cirrus...
Yeah, but what... I'm so confused.
Cirrus Stratus...
Cirrus... Oh, okay, Cirrus...
Stratus 0, 6...
Oh, I get it!
I get it!
Oh, okay, okay, okay...
Okay,
so 10, 13...
Cirrus... Oh, okay, okay, okay...
9...
Stratus...
16, 14, 16, 14...
16...
Clear skies... Oh, no, sorry, Cirrus...
Oh, God, I can't remember these.
It's not here...
Cirrus Stratus Cirrus Cumulonimbus, okay...
So, Cirrus 0, Stratus 6...
Cirrus 0...
9... 0, 6, 0, 9!
Oh, hey!
I need to open it!
I need to open it, sorry!
Oh, it worked!
He was gonna get me anyway.
0...
6, 0...
Yippee!
Yeah, I am!
Oh, we got the locations of the medicines!
Cool.
Oh, I'm gonna eat a bread.
And I'm gonna take your cookie.
Nice.
Anything in here?
Nothing?
Wow!
They got the biggest toilet paper ever!
Pee pee smell...
Okay.
Time to go home.
I do wanna go buy some books.
I wish I could fast travel.
I'm just gonna run.
The city is right there.
Don't stop running, Indy!
Don't stop running!
Hit like that from Minto would send me to...
Hey now, buddy.
Have some dignity.
Damn it.
I'm running.
I'm running away.
You don't have to be so curious.
Indiana Jones, Cookie Thief.
It does feel like that.
It truly does feel like that.
Hey, is this the basket that one person was looking for?
No.
She's like, that's my basket.
Never had in this fandom.
Fair.
Minky!
Is that a dinosaur?
Oh, I thought it was a... Okay.
I thought it was a Stegosaurus!
From far away, I thought it was a Stegosaurus!
What's that?
No.
These are notes.
These are mysteries.
These are books.
I thought these were the Moxies!
Oh, the Moxie is at...
Moxie is with the medicine man.
I thought it was a Stegosaurus.
You guys see it too, right?
You guys saw it too?
So now we've been to everywhere, right?
We haven't.
Workers area.
What?
How have I not been to everywhere?
I'm going in.
Excuse me.
Hello.
Don't mind me.
Nice.
Quick grab.
What's this?
A letter.
What is it?
Mayor's letter?
I know that you hate the man's guts as much as I do, but I feel like we have to do something about it soon.
Vos has been pushing my men to work harder and harder while being deliberately vague about what it is we are working towards.
If a man bores him, Vos will make a game of dissecting his psychology and breaking him.
Just last week, two otherwise sane men fled into the desert without water after a private conversation with Vos.
I know he has powerful connections, but something has to be done.
Mayor.
Who's looking at me?
Stop checking me out, you freak.
Oh Kendra!
Thank you for the raid!
Hello, hello.
Hello everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome in.
Oh see, we need to peel the buses open.
What's this?
Haunting!
I have heard reports that many of the soldiers refused to enter the tomb west of the workers' camp.
Rumors say that it's cursed, that it is haunted by ghosts.
Apparently some of them can even hear whispers at night coming from the entrance.
I've had the tomb entrance sealed for now, but we must do something to improve the men's morale.
Maybe a cinema showing would cheer them up.
The tomb entrance which has been sealed.
Oh, can you...
Do you think if I break this open while they are here, they will get upset?
Will they get mad if I do that?
Sorry, I was just yawning.
How
do I get them?
Oh, hi.
Yeah!
What is he looking at?
Distract him with a bottle?
Will it work?
Stealth 100.
Come here!
Did us Wisps come out that arc?
Okay,
I don't have anything.
I don't think I have anything.
That's cool though.
It worked!
It totally worked!
I'm so stealthy!
Hey!
Indy, just take...I wasn't going to take any of them!
I was just saying, take a break!
Take a break Indy!
Don't!
Increase health...
Oh,
good!
Okay, we can either do more cardio or more health.
I feel like stamina is probably better than health at this rate.
I think
the Djinn is coming for him.
Mama!
Thanks for a month!
Wait, did I not get Moxie one before?
Oh, but I should either buy one or...
Okay,
shut up.
I'm trying to make a decision.
One costs less.
Yeah, I guess that's true.
I don't think I bought the other one.
Yeah, we got HP last time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Moxie.
You know what?
I'm just going to get all of them.
What have I not?
Splinter Smash?
I haven't unlocked that one.
Okay, I've unlocked everything that I can now.
Cool.
I don't know.
Should we do the haunted one, you guys?
I feel like we have to.
I want to do the haunted one and then we can go to the Sphinx.
It's over here.
It's right here.
Easy peasy.
I'm scared!
I can hear the whispers.
I'm scared.
Okay, I'll hold your hand.
Okay.
Wait.
What?
I didn't... No.
I don't know why they give me this stuff.
It kind of freaks me out.
Am I going to die in here?
Why is it so scary?
Oh my god.
No way.
Okay.
I hope whoever reads this is a friend.
Know that I am a spy of N.
The Nachos must not have this artifact.
I could not smuggle it out of here.
It seems important.
They are on to me.
I feel them watching me during the work shift.
I don't have much time.
I hope this radio and the haunted sounds will scare them off long enough.
The Nachos are very stupid.
So I should buy us some time.
Maybe they will leave before they find it.
If god wills it.
This is exactly what Minto ASMR will sound like.
No way.
It was just a recording?
Guys, ghosts are real.
Don't get it twisted.
I was so excited for some grand adventure in the haunted area.
No,
they are not.
Yes, they are.
It's literally me.
Are you okay?
I don't think he is okay.
He is not taking it very well.
Alright, let's... wait, what's over there?
I want to see what that is and then we will fast travel to the Sphinx.
Let's see if there is any goodies over here.
Money?
A cookie?
Take.
Noice.
Okay, I'll go.
No, you are a fake ghost.
I'm not a fake ghost!
I'm the realest ghost.
I'm the real ghost.
I'm the realest real ghost.
Ask me any sort of ghost question.
I believe you are a ghost if you haunt me tonight.
I'm already haunting you right now.
Technically I'm haunting you tonight.
Ghosts can't wear hats.
What?
How would you even... why would you even think that?
Ghosts can definitely wear hats.
Where is the... oh here it is.
Sphinx time!
Sphinx.
3 plus 3.
That's it.
Oh I have to go to this part.
I was gonna say, am I going back inside?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Yu Yuko wears a hat.
That's what I'm saying!
I'm taking another picture?
Oh yeah that's right.
We're gonna... we're gonna go investigate the dream stele.
OK.
What now?
Oh, solve the dream stele.
Find clues.
0 out of 4.
OK.
Guardian symbol.
Where?
Zoom in.
OK.
God!
Right there.
Oh I see!
I'm supposed to like find... maybe that?
There?
This one?
And this one?
This one.
Great Pyramid.
Khufu?
OK.
Where's my map?
All the way!
Over there baby!
Alright!
Maybe I should have done this way long ago and then I could have run all the way over there.
I just realized I can get up here.
Oops!
Can I though?
Come on Indy!
Indy!
There we go.
Did someone notice me?
No!
What's up in here?
Money.
Let's see if I can hit someone from here.
I tried.
Uhm...
We'll wait.
We'll go down the other way.
Or I could just run.
You know what?
Let's just run.
Go Indy!
Indy run!
Indy get out of there!
Phew!
If you ask me, this is a shoe-in for Indy Game of the Year.
Onwards.
OK we are going to the base of the pyramid.
This guy is going to catch us probably.
OK good.
I thought he was going to clock us.
That's a dog!
Uh-oh.
The dog won't get us though, right?
Dog is friend?
Dog is friend.
Dog.
Dog knows stinky smell.
Oh this guy is...
I'm trying to do a shortcut but it ended up being weird.
OK.
I can probably go around this area.
So I don't have to go through the camp.
Wherever I am.
Camp... what's her name?
Get it?
Indy Game!
Yeah, you can't pet the dog though.
And it really does influence my score of the game.
Believe it or not.
I would receive a much higher score if you could pet the dogs.
It's great that you can take pictures of the dogs and the cats, but...
It's like...
Come on.
Hello?
What's wrong with this?
OK, nevermind.
Slacker!
Almost a 7 hour stream.
I honestly haven't even noticed.
I'm so into this game.
I'm so into it.
I'm so much fun with this game.
It's so fun.
Oh, it's a train.
I thought someone was running after me.
Am I allowed to be here?
Yeah, we're fine.
Is this guy gonna clock me?
Bless you.
Oh my gosh, we're almost to the base of the pyramid.
OK, right over here?
I haven't been to this area yet.
Let's see if they have any money I can take.
Steely!
I'm about to steely too.
Oh, nevermind.
Take that.
This is it?
OK.
Yeah, this area.
It's our steely guy.
Steely...
Oh see, now this looks suspicious.
That's the symbol!
There it is.
Glad I took that.
Yeah!
How did nobody notice this?
That's how I always feel about the other movies too.
I'm like, how did anybody not notice this?
I think I need a highlighter.
That doesn't look breakable.
No.
People just don't go smashing walls?
I guess not.
What is it?
How can you tell?
They all look the same.
Chamber of resonance.
Like a resonance chamber.
Oh boy, am I going to have to...
Am I going to have to solve this language?
Hold on, answer your question after J.
Thank you!
That means?
Brainblast!
Oh my god, he's getting crazy eyes.
I was wondering if it was ok to use some of your karaoke songs...
into a custom vinyl record as a Christmas gift.
Oh my god, of course J!
That sounds insane!
Thank you!
I don't think my...
I don't think my karaoke's are high quality enough to sound like...
Official...
Official record, official recording is all...
Ok Yeah?
Do I do it in a certain order?
Search for clues 3 out of 6.
Do I do it?
Oh, do I do it in a certain order?
Ok, ok, maybe.
Maybe?
The game begs to differ.
Wait, what am I wrong about?
I already took this picture.
Is there anything on here I take a picture of?
So creepy!
So creepy.
How about this guy?
No hand.
Don't like that.
That's a little freaky.
Maybe this is the real haunted...
This is the real haunted...
Area.
Oh!
That's so nice of them.
Ok And then we connect this...
Tablet piece.
And take a picture.
And that should be it.
Ok Ok
Heed?
Protect?
Oath?
The Lord's?
Heed?
Maybe protect?
Oh, ok, wait.
I was gonna say protect the secret in the name of the Lord.
Well, maybe it's the Lord.
Heed?
The Lord's?
Oath.
Heed the Lord's Oath.
So Heed?
The Lord's?
Oath?
I don't know of the name where to put that though.
Protect the secret...Oh protect the secret of the name!
Protect...the secret...of the name.
Oh no!
Nice Good job!
We did it guys!
That was...that was that guy!
Oh gosh!
That was the giant!
Paragon!
Guys, we play some freaky games.
Underground cave system.
Ancient cave maps.
Love that we have that on hand with us.
Can I still...oh no, ok.
That's actually a little dangerous maybe.
Hey!
That was such a clean swing.
How did he learn this language so fast?
It's kind of insane.
Indiana Jones How are you brained the way that you are?
Oh he's reading the hieroglyphics.
That makes more sense.
The cave was sealed.
Were we not supposed to unseal this?
Did you guys hear that?
Predator, right?
Right?
Under the command of King Khufu, stones rose to the sky.
A testament to his power.
The pyramids.
What a nice gift that my favorite cute ghostmate is streaming on my birthday!
Thanks for all the laughs and fun this year and congrats on 300k.
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday...sorry how did she know this?
To you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Pandore!
Happy birthday and thank you!
I appreciate it.
Bats!
I wonder how much longer I have of this game.
There is definitely whispers.
There is definitely whispers?
Alright spy...
You don't have to pull another prank on us now.
Raw?
A lot?
No way, seriously?
Still another big area to go?
Wait, seriously?
Only halfway through the game?
No way.
No way, are you serious?
I thought...
When I looked it up, it said it was like 9 hours.
That's it.
Oh my god.
There is like 3 more chapters?
Ok, we are not finishing it today then.
Damn, what?
Oh my god.
9 hours for speedrun, that must be it.
Well, it was like the day the game...
Or not like the day the game came out, but it was...
Not long after the game came out, so...
It probably was like skewed to people who...
Were like speedrunning it.
But dang.
Dang, I really felt like we were coming up on the end too.
Neolithic?
No, no, this is...
Even older.
Tens of thousands of years before the ancient Egyptians.
Spooky.
Ancient relic.
Oh my god, I hate these things.
They are the most boring looking relics ever.
They are so stupid.
You know what?
I complained earlier about how slow it is to walk around.
Are those ants?
What the hell is it?
What?
Smash, smash, smash, smash.
Squish, squish, squish, squish.
Let's just...
Three-eyed gate.
That's a great question.
With these babies.
These bad boys.
So we have this one.
We got this one.
Oh, we're missing one.
Dang.
I don't think I'll be able to beat it before Japan then.
No.
That's okay.
We'll just come back.
I'm not gone for so long anyway.
If I move you upwards...
Or upwards...
Or overwards...
What opens?
What just opened?
Nothing opened?
Anything opened?
Something moved.
I definitely heard it.
You're going back to Japan?
What for?
I...
Oh, it's like rumbling.
I only knew because my...
My controller started rumbling.
I only knew that this changed.
Oh, it changes to what it is.
Oh, that's so interesting.
My favorite idol group is disbanding.
So sad.
So I am going to go see them.
Their final show.
Oh, okay, so we use these to create...
So we...
We use the light to combine the symbols to create...
What is shown on there.
I see, okay.
Oh, neat.
So like this one will turn into...
Oh, it opened.
Perfect.
Are they going to get into this symbol though?
Maybe some symbols... Well, that doesn't look like any of the symbols.
So maybe some symbols are only for...
For entering areas?
Perhaps?
What's crazy in here is there's no skeletons or anything.
Like it actually feels untouched.
So scary.
Oh my god, imagine you moved it and it showed on a person.
That would be so scary.
There's like a guy standing in there.
Like a g-g-g-ghost.
Oh, it's a weak scoob.
I don't think I can go in here at all.
So let's see.
Like this?
Plus...
This ties to this.
Maybe?
Did I just open something?
Oh, I did.
British Shaggy.
No.
Yeah, we'll have to take it to the other one.
It's so cool seeing the light.
I like it.
Alrighty.
Perfect!
OK.
My bad.
What's that light?
Oh, just the day.
Just the sun.
So...
See how it's kind of creating?
I'm trying to make this one, but...
Am I missing something?
It's not quite...
Oh, I think I need that.
I think I need this.
Yeah!
The X.
OK.
That's the first one.
Now we need this one.
And...oh, the X too?
Or...yeah?
That one?
Which one has a circle in the middle?
I think that one...
And then...the X.
It sounds so cool.
Oh my god, this is so Indiana Jones.
So awesome.
Yeah!
Woah!
Little ants, little...woah!
Little ants, little ants.
Mess up your drawing, little ants.
Alright, last one is...
Is this...
Plus this...
Plus this?
I think?
It's magnetic sand.
No, it's little ants.
Shut up.
And
then...what was the last one I said?
I don't remember.
This bottom one, right?
Woah!
I'm a genius!
First try!
If there's one thing I'm good at, it's patterns!
I bought a magic wand!
No way, you bought a Metal Gear Solid.
You got the MG...wait, you got the Patchy Solid!
Don't blame me!
First try, baby.
Oh, but what's over here?
I see the gamer paint, but...
What?
I hear so many noises.
Gamer paint, gamer paint.
I feel like I need to change into an indie outfit.
Right?
Ain't you the best?
I don't know how.
Holy moly.
I feel like I gotta be in my adventurous outfit.
You know?
For this adventure.
There's so many noises!
So many noises.
Find a way across.
Wow!
Oh my god.
This game turned way more into an adventure than I thought it would become.
Anything?
Don't fall, Indie, don't fall!
Maybe not.
Minecraft, yeah.
Jack Black comes out and he goes, I am Steve.
What about...
Good job.
Nice strong ankles.
What is that?
Is that a little part that I'm supposed to...
Wait, there's gamer...
There's gamer paint.
Gamer paint, gamer paint!
Huh?
Now I know I'm not crazy.
There are subtitles for it.
Is that a car horn?
It scared me.
I was like, I thought it was a part of the game at first.
I was like, huh?
And then the whisper started.
And I'm like, huh?
Wait, how do I get over to that one?
Oh gosh, the light is so bright.
Indie, Indie, don't fall.
You know what, actually this works.
Maybe I did it anyway.
I made it across!
Why are there such creepy whispers happening?
Creepy whispers happening and clicking happening.
Oh here.
Dead...
I
even mentioned earlier, I was like, there are no skellies.
Just like us.
The clicking isn't your controller?
No.
No, it's not.
I like how there are different ways you can go.
The game doesn't limit you and make you be like, you went the wrong way, you have to turn all the way around.
What if he just fell in?
I got it.
I know I feel like I should bring that, but I also...
I'm scared.
I need the light more than that.
Where are his clothes?
Back then he didn't need any.
According to Michael Bay, Transformers built the pyramids, so maybe the car horn is their cause.
I've been sick, took a nap, I'm not wearing my glasses for a couple of seconds, my brain registered this as Minecraft.
You're not so far off.
I hope you feel better, Casey.
These aren't gonna move, are they?
Wait.
I thought I heard other footsteps.
Oh gosh, the game is saving me.
Cave of Darkness?
Yeah, I don't like that.
What?
Don't like that.
Creepy.
This is so creepy.
If that's gone, I might lose it.
I might call it, you guys.
If that...
Look, there's more bones.
If whatever that was standing over there wasn't just...
A statue.
And moves.
Oh my god.
Will something attack me in the darkness?
Is that why these are here?
The giant attack in the darkness.
We learned that.
All the money.
Oh okay, it's just a statue.
Thank god.
I completed it?
I don't like this.
I don't like it.
They kept saying that the giants would fight in the darkness.
And I knew that eventually I would have to fight one.
Oh, but I really don't want to.
Here he comes.
I see
him coming.
I see him coming.
Oh god!
Why am I...
At least I got that.
Oh my god, I can't see him.
Oh my god!
Okay, it's not so bad because they give you lots of time to like...
What's the word?
Oh, I think he's coming.
God, I tried to block.
Oh...
Yeah, lots of time to like just chill out and be like...
Oh god, help me.
I'm trying to stay off the coins, but he throws me onto them sometimes.
I don't know if this will...
I don't know if he hears that.
There we go.
I see, I just ate.
I think that's important information.
Don't say it.
No, that's the thing.
He's not supposed to say it.
Deathrattle?
We just killed this guy.
Indy, that's the important thing.
Don't say it.
You don't say it.
Not gun, sorry.
This.
Here we go.
Is it here?
Sorry guy.
You're really old.
This way?
Onwards?
What's this?
Ass up.
That's not how he died.
That means Indiana Jones flipped him on his back.
I guess to get the... No, he got the pendant.
The buttons on the floor?
Oh, thank you.
Oh yeah, that's right.
We have to...
We have to step on them, right?
Where was the other one?
There's this one, and that one, and then one more, right?
Where was it?
Was it over here?
Here.
There we go.
Guardian pendant.
Alrighty.
Are we the bad guy?
We might be.
But we're not the baddest guys.
Look at that guy.
He does not care about you, Indiana Jones.
He's just a little guy.
And guess who tailed us the entire time?
We're gonna be seeing Emerick's face real soon, I bet.
Where the hell did we come from?
Oh yeah, that's right.
We fell down, right?
Narwhal.
Damn, Minto.
She's really a genius.
Did someone... Did you have a bad trip?
Should we not take heed to these skellies?
To these dead guys and why they could have potentially died from a trap?
Nope.
Okay.
This looks suspicious.
Was this room gonna fill with sand or something?
Oh god.
The idol of Ra.
It was just here.
Oh my god, it's so bright.
Here we go.
This is what everybody is after.
There it is.
Indy, pay attention please.
Indy, the door.
Indiana Jones!
Indiana Jones.
Some of the skeletons are where other players died during the game.
No, they're not.
He got it.
The piece to the great circle.
Don't make me do it.
Oh no!
I knew it was gonna fill up with sand!
Oh god, I can't move.
I can barely move.
I'm gonna die.
What?
You die so fast.
Okay, okay, okay.
Exit.
Where?
Up there.
How can I reach it?
How can I reach?
Just go upwards?
Just keep grabbing.
Go!
Go Indy please!
Indy!
Go!
Oh god, I just fell.
How awkward.
That's fine.
Let's just keep going.
I made it!
First try!
Where's our hat?
Our hat?
I made it!
See that's what I said!
Where's your hat?
Is it on your pants?
Or is that just sand?
His dang hat.
His smirk smile.
Oh there's the hat!
He got his cheese.
Nice cheese block.
Everyone's worst panicking moment.
A tiny ledge.
Oh my god.
Indy please.
Please.
Oh my god.
Why didn't you keep it in your pocket?
I can't.
They are going to steal it right under his nose.
Literally.
Is that a piece of the great circle in your pants or are you just happy to see me?
Enjoying the sun?
Piss by piss.
Indiana Jones!
Get up.
I can hear your gears turning now.
Yeah, it doesn't matter who solved it.
If the person who takes it.
It doesn't matter.
This guy is such a goof.
He spits everywhere.
Oh my god.
You can see the spit on his lips.
He's so nasty.
No!
Get his ass in.
He looks so pathetic.
Help.
Uppies please.
I'm trying to move.
Oh god.
It's bright.
Himalayas?
Wait, are we going to...
It's a harsh climb anytime.
You've been to Antarctica, the Himalayas, or nothing?
It's like my other... what's it called?
My other fixation.
Let me uppies please.
What are you going to do with me?
Don't you dare.
My eyes are so bright.
Thank you.
Please.
Give me up.
There they go.
And then they're all gone just like that.
No way.
Where did this guy come from?
Are you serious?
Oh I'm supposed to be blowing.
Oh no.
Are you kidding me?
I didn't know this was part of the game.
Oh my god.
I have no stamina.
No!
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die to this...
Oh my god.
I'm blowing!
I have no stamina!
Oh my god.
Help me please!
Oh my god I was literally on 1 HP in a dream.
No way!
Help me!
I wonder if it's scripted.
Oh we're dying.
We're so dead.
I didn't realize I was supposed to be blowing at first.
I think he needs an antidote.
I'm glad you're still alive.
You're beginning to grow on me Jones.
I actually died to the scorpions there.
Oh you can die?
Wow.
Again?
Oh he took it.
The Great Circle.
Machu Picchu.
Oh...
Ah!
Wait we gave her the...wait no.
Yeah we gave the...no we never gave it to her I guess technically.
Her boat!
We're on the boat.
I like this soft version of his theme song.
It's so cute.
Nice boat.
Not nice boat.
We're not nice boat.
Cute.
I don't think it's a death flag.
It's not really Indiana Jones' style to kill off the world.
And you couldn't get another shirt.
You know what's so funny is I paid for that.
It's the Temple of Doom outfit so it's all like messed up.
It's supposed to be...
What was the German...Oh yeah!
I mean they did kill her off.
That's true.
Yeah this is true.
What?
Oh my god stop the Sherpas...No!
Oh my god Indiana Jones is about to...
Make up another body on Everest.
What the hell?
No she's dead now.
Food for the mountain.
Please be a dinosaur.
It sounds like a dinosaur but...
Sherpa ain't having it.
Stinky Everest.
This is before it became stinky.
I cannot believe it.
I can't believe we're here.
I'm trying to decide if I want to keep going.
I guess I'll get to like not...
Whatever this area is.
It would be so much less visible.
Oh my god the way...
The way Gina's NPC works she's not gonna make it you guys.
There we go.
She's not gonna make it.
Not with the way her NPC works.
There's a good stopping point ahead.
Okay perfect.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 20 gifts.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This would be a way...This is like actually not so bad visibility.
All things considered.
You wouldn't even be able to see right in front of your feet.
Oh my god.
Gina!
Oh my god!
There she goes!
Oh my god.
Girl!
I'm going.
Better let me try it first!
She goes anyway.
I think she's actually trying to kill us honestly.
She's actually going to betray us.
Wait what's this way?
What's down there?
Oh my god.
This is so scary.
Death probably.
Yeah probably.
Oh up here?
Oh my god I can see her footsteps.
The snow looks so powdery and nice.
Gina no!
Gina please let me go first!
Okay she's just stepping on air.
I get it.
I would hope not.
Oh the snow crunch sounds so good right?
Don't go down there maybe.
Let's keep going up.
Snow crunch.
What do you mean?
It is here!
We literally heard him say Himalayas.
Yeah!
It's a ship!
A ship?
What?
Oh my god that's amazing.
This is so awesome!
No!
I don't want to wait until I come back home for me to...
For me to learn mystery!
Feels like Uncharted now.
Just wait.
Let me do it first.
Just kidding.
You seeing this too?
Yeah!
It's a ship!
Good!
But I'm not crazy!
Ancient aliens are the best.
Let's get a closer look.
What was I supposed to do?
Oh now I can grab on to it.
Hey!
Me first!
No!
Dice!
I don't know!
That's insane!
That is so awesome!
What a grueling...Oh my gosh!
What a...like the anchor just like dangling in the wind.
Oh my god!
The...
It's such a cool visual!
Oh my god!
And like the sounds it's making!
I'm like freaking out.
It's so awesome.
I don't think it's Noah's Ark.
It has literal guns on it.
You can see them.
Wow!
It looks so awesome.
Like look at it!
Wow!
And like the sounds.
Like the...
Like the creaking and everything.
Anything?
Ok.
I don't think any kind of picture is going to look good in this but...
The ship that disappeared!
The one that disappeared in Peru!
Comet!
Oh my god!
The snow is so deep.
It's so awesome!
Oh my god!
The audio design is so incredible here.
I'm sorry.
I keep freaking out because it sounds so good!
Probably.
It's so creepy.
Is it even stable?
I don't quite think so.
Oh look!
We can see the ledge where we came from!
It does?
Oh my god.
Little frozen...
Where do I go?
Limp.
Where do I go from here?
Oh in here?
Maybe?
Oh here we go.
Help her.
Shadow!
Welcome to Batmusha!
Thank you!
The sounds of creaking metal are so good.
I know!
It's so freaky!
Hello?
Why did he look like that?
Oh my god.
It's so chilly in here.
Somehow.
I don't think it will let us back out.
Or I think I can...
It's so freaky in here!
Wait.
I don't want to end quite yet.
I'm going to keep going a little bit more.
Sorry.
Is anyone alive in here?
Like did they just send the guys?
A ghost ship.
Did they just send the guys here like this?
Congrats on 300k.
Thank you!
It might turn into a 12 hour stream.
Probably not.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Probably not.
Maybe.
Who knows.
I don't know.
Probably not.
It's already 11PM for me.
I still haven't finished my dinner.
This place seems chill.
Is it attached to a hand?
Frozen.
Damn!
Nah, I don't need that.
Hand it over?
Prepare to fight the Yeti monster.
Don't say that!
But being Indiana Jones I can't tell what's serious and what's not.
Buckle up.
Thank you.
What?
This way?
Oh.
Search the ship.
That's so freaky.
What is this now?
This thing?
Right here?
Oh, other side?
We gotta go back to the handle.
Which was down this way.
Right here.
Hehehe.
Oh my god.
Survivors account.
I think almost half of the crew is dead now.
Yeah, there's like 15 of them.
We need to remove bodies.
But it can wait.
The cold slows the rot.
I organize the surviving members of my division into groups.
One is scouting the larder for supplies and the others are trying to find anything burnable.
Heat is a higher priority than food right now.
We can endure long enough for rescue to arrive.
But some are not cooperative.
Move, Jaina!
A group of the men declared the mess their territory.
They shoot anyone who tries to get in.
Another group abandoned their post and went...
Wait, does that mean...
I wonder if those guys are still alive.
We're going to find Luke Skywalker upside down with that giant yeti-like monster.
What do you mean this is the wrong air support movie?
Another group abandoned their post and went outside in a foolish attempt to climb down the mountain and find help.
No one knows where the captain and his officers are.
Cowards.
We can survive this, but only if we work together for the greater good.
None of you took off your clothes and tried to huddle up together.
Look, they're all frowning.
This guy has the pole going through his face.
None of you even tried to do that.
Oh gosh, there's so many of them.
We're just chilling in here.
Get it?
lol
Oh, sad.
Oh my god!
This one is so bad.
You're awful for that.
What?
Oh my god, this too.
Let's go upstairs.
There's just guys everywhere.
Guys everywhere.
They're nachos.
Yeah.
Sometimes it saves at really random parts and I'm like, why are you saving, huh?
Oh!
Take a bandage.
Did I lose all my stuff?
No.
I guess we won't be finding any fruit in here though, huh?
Well, maybe bread.
I'm interested in the mess hall.
Wait.
I thought I heard whispering.
You think I can... let's see.
Let's try and shatter this guy.
No.
Someone more accessible.
Him?
No.
Move, Gina.
Why
is the music getting all freaky?
All of a sudden.
No.
Okay.
But we still have to search the whole ship to find him.
Will we not?
Gina!
Go!
Alright.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
It's so scary.
I love it, but I hate it.
I love scary!
Why does she look so sassy?
Who's watching her?
What?
What do you see?
Do you see the stone?
No.
Oh no.
So that boss guy was lying even then.
That guy was lying then.
He was just like, oh she's happy with us, blah blah blah.
Oh she's, you know, she's fine.
And she's working with us.
Oh no.
I need to know what happened here.
I didn't know you could do that with the camera.
Yeah, you can move it around in cutscenes, but it doesn't really add much.
How did she know it was her?
Maybe she just was like sisterly sense.
Like MGS2 codec.
What was that?
A workers permit?
Oh no!
They're here!
They didn't get much time at all, huh?
Oh.
Oh an idea.
Nacho idea.
Fold the earth?
Oh my god, they're coming.
We hear them.
Don't cry, your tears will freeze.
Yeah, maybe like a wormhole or something.
Cool.
Oh my god!
I'm not gonna let you shoot that!
Hey!
These guys are tough.
These guys are tough!
Oh my god, she just went after them.
I thought I had a weapon.
I guess it's gone now.
Oh we can see her.
Oh it's kind of freaky.
I am just looking at your dead sister real quick.
Hold on.
Let's see if there is anything else around here.
Hold on!
You do this to me every time Gina!
You rush me!
You rush me Gina!
And I'm an explorer and I'm a hoarder!
Ok Gina!
You have to understand Gina!
This is just my way of doing things!
Yes!
I'm gonna take this.
I wish I could hold multiple weapons.
Maybe I will take the shotgun.
Hold on.
Sad.
You can't bring it up the stairs.
Indy is so fragile.
Indy is very, very fragile.
You guys please understand.
Watch your back.
How do they set up everything so fast?
I'm following you.
Oh maybe I shouldn't have.
Where are you going?
Ok, where am I going?
We are going... where this way?
What?
I saw something.
Everyone is dead.
Keep going?
Oh, we are about to get spotted but not really.
Now you are just imagining things.
Where am I going?
I'm going further away from where I need to go.
What's going on?
What do you mean?
He is acting like we are his subordinates.
Come here.
Gina, where are you?
I need some backup.
Oh my god!
Gina, I thought you were a guy!
Gina!
I don't remember how to look over...
I got him.
Only 6 shots.
Gina!
Maybe I shouldn't have sniped him.
It's fine.
We can go through here.
Gina, don't go that way.
Real stealth moments.
What?
Oh my god!
I thought you were... Jesus, girl!
God!
I'm actually trying to be sneaky here, okay?
Don't go over there.
Not yet.
Yellow equals friend.
Let's see if we can get past him.
Fuck!
Get ragdolled.
This looks like it could be the captain.
He flew.
Girl, hide.
I'm just gonna shoot anybody.
He sounds so close.
That's why it's so freaking me out.
Gina, are you okay?
Who just loaded?
Anyway...
Through here?
I think.
I think she's okay.
Too fun.
God!
Why were you reverse gripping the gun?
Because it ran out of bullets and that's what happens when you run out of bullets.
Oh man, we got so far.
Why me don't know heal?
I forgot.
That's why.
Yeah, the masked guys are tricky.
They are not easy.
Is that me?
Am I going...
Did I just cough?
Why am I so cold?
Do I need more food or something?
Do I need more food?
Why am I so cold?
I wasn't shivering like this before though.
I'm nervous.
Oh no.
A man down.
Nothing.
I got him.
Oh shit.
Fire?
Don't do that.
Gina, watch out.
Can I grab a shotgun?
Oh shit.
I could headshot, but I'm not.
I made it.
Oh my god Gina.
Where are you?
Don't just brush off like nothing happened.
Come on girl.
Is there anything down here that I can use?
Two bullets.
Four bullets.
Five bullets.
I can count.
Anyway, where are we going?
Over here?
What's that?
Maybe I will take that instead.
Try not to alert too many guards, you know?
Why does it look less frozen in these places?
They just got here.
Oh hi raiders!
I don't know who raided me, but...
Hello, hello!
Playing Indiana Jones and it's very mysterious and fun.
Very mysterious and fun.
Over here.
More dead guys.
Oh the game just saved?
Nice.
They are here.
Something.
Camera.
What am I taking a picture of?
Ahem.
Miuna.
Hello!
Thank you!
He's like yeah I'm gonna check it out.
Casey thanks for the five!
Gifted Deku!
Glad you are still alive.
Yeah!
Oh my god this guy doesn't even have shoes.
Oh there is a chain in the way?
I...
Honestly don't know when to stop.
Oh.
Thanks mod.
Woah 8 hours.
Yeah I really like this game!
It's a lot of fun!
What am I getting rid of?
The chain?
Hold on.
Let me go up there.
Check out what she's looking at.
Chain?
Train.
Do you think I can make that?
I don't know what she's talking about.
Oh this one.
What did I say?
I would take care of it?
What am I gonna do about it?
What am I supposed to do about it?
Just go under?
I don't know.
What do you want me to do?
Better keep looking for... What?
Indy what are you talking about?
Try punching it?
Punch the ice.
Let's see.
There is obviously a way that I can...
Something to do down there but I'm not quite sure.
Go down.
Please stop floating you freak of nature.
Rub your hands together then touch the ice.
That's not something we do.
Let me just see what this is.
Be careful Indy.
Maybe I go down here.
No, no.
Down.
Maybe.
Is there something down here?
What's this?
Punch the ice.
No Indy come on!
There is no weapon here to break it.
You gotta do... Wait.
Maybe I can throw it down here.
Ok hold on.
Lick the ice.
Pee on the ice.
Look at the chain.
Hold on!
Hold on with the chain!
I just found a secret area.
And there was a thing to break it.
Close by.
I thought.
I thought I had one.
Gosh this is so ominous and spooky.
There was something wasn't there?
So bright.
I'll take that.
I even missed something.
I can break it with the gun.
There we go.
Perfect.
Flirt with the chain.
I love the way you...
link together.
Your big bulky...
steel...
Something.
I don't know what you're made out of.
Bye!
Alright, there we go.
And that here.
No, come on.
There we go.
Good job.
What's in here?
I've been rewarded?
For my bravery?
Comic book!
Wow!
Yeah!
The terrible thing from below!
That's true.
That is absolutely true.
My own gun.
I do quite forget often that I have my own gun.
Ok.
The chain.
This is the chain.
I'll be the chain.
Yank the chain!
We can do that?
How did that work?
And from here?
Oh, I think we're going to get separated.
Oh, nevermind.
We're not going to get separated.
We're fine.
Whip 2 OP.
Hold on.
Gina?
I'm trapped over here.
There we go.
Whip is god level.
Why do you think Indiana Jones uses it all the time?
At least it won't have the anchor pulling down the ship on the edge now, right?
Maybe.
So we're going out?
Why are we doing that?
Why am I crouching?
Come on.
Oh, you think he's on the escape boat?
That would be so funny.
If the captain was on the life boat.
Or not the life boat, you know.
Yup.
Let's keep going.
Yeah.
Life boat is right?
Oh, I was right?
Ok.
Thank you.
Sometimes I feel like I get things confused.
I get terminologies confused.
Push!
I'm so glad I remembered.
I can't believe it's an achievement.
That's hilarious.
Wow, that's such a good sound of the...
Can I push this guy?
Push!
Is
Gina down?
No!
Oh god, it's this guy.
I hate this guy.
You suck!
No!
You push!
Push you!
You alright?
We got it.
We're fine everybody.
Don't worry.
Everything's ok.
Probably.
Nice.
I tried to push that guy.
Didn't really work.
More bodies for Everest to eat.
Photo?
What am I taking a photo?
Oh, life boat.
Maybe he's on it.
Wow, it looks like it's starting to clear up though.
Mint brought a pipe to a gunfight and won.
Hell yeah I did.
Gosh, I really am appreciative of how...
I don't need games to hold my hand entirely.
You know, obviously.
But it is nice that if they're just like...
If you need to know where to go next, we got you.
Ok, well there's nothing else around here so...
I won!
It's a fair game.
Wow.
I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Ok.
Back up!
Gina!
He's gonna turn around.
Oh, there she goes.
He's right there.
Holy shit.
Girl.
Oh my god, I can't with her.
Oh, I got him.
I'm better than that guy.
Oh, document.
Experiment journal!
Oh yes!
Experiment delta circle zero.
Location.
Off the coast of Peru, 50 kilometers west of Lima.
Log written.
Purpose of experiment.
To gauge any intrinsic powers within the great circle artifact stone.
Discovered during the Machu Picchu expedition 1937.
Account.
Present are myself, Dr. Laura.
Her sister.
And Captain Conrad.
Together with the crew of KMS Comet.
Oh, oh!
Emmerich Voss observes the experiment from a nearby ship along with the other expedition members.
Everyone is gathered around the stone, which has been placed on a makeshift pedestal.
Dr. Lombardi objects once again to the experiment being conducted in this manner.
Citing the speculative nature of her compiled syllabary and the lack of theoretical understanding of potential risks.
She considers the experiment to be reckless and dangerous.
Well, we know that it was hops... hops... hops... hopskitch.
Hopskitch.
Yes, she wasn't wrong.
The captain reminds Dr. Lombardi that it is just a rock, not to waste his time.
He further emphasizes that she will have to answer to hopskitch.
Voss, if she does not follow his orders.
After a brief discussion, Dr. Lombardi reluctantly agrees to proceed with the experiment.
She takes the stone in her left hand, holds it up and begins to document.
Ends abruptly.
She began to...
Fortnite emo all over the place.
I'm not sure.
Unrelated, sorry.
I just got the notification that my happy is shipping soon.
They've been working on shipping the happy.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, right over here.
Nice.
What's this?
A sketch.
Of...
It's a sketch of Mickey!
Mayan sketch.
Sketch of a Mayan statue presumably found before the Peru exposition.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is a bed.
I didn't expect him to be so... round.
I don't know.
Oh, golly.
Oh, wait.
I'm full health.
Just kidding.
Straight goblin.
Is this the captain?
No.
Where am I?
Am I in the right place?
Close.
I think I need to go upstairs.
Anything over here?
Alright, upstairs.
Maybe I will never understand why Laura was here.
But at least I can try to stop Voss from getting the stone.
Yeah.
We'll stop him.
Maybe.
I don't know.
They have more... There's only two of us and like a lot of them.
Officer Lounge!
I think Jogham is the captain.
Oh, just kidding.
All the letter combinations have been crossed out.
Just kidding.
Wow!
I like how it glistens.
It's so pretty.
Code wheel.
I think we know what to do.
What do you mean nothing?
I'm trying!
Oh, baby.
Everybody put 4, 5, 7, 1 in the chat.
Oh my gosh.
I love it when you call me 4, 5, 7, 1.
Better baby!
Oh my gosh.
4, 5, 7, 1.
Are these numbers here?
No, they are letters.
J.
Can I change it?
Hey, 4, 5, 7, 1.
You come here often?
What's this?
Viewers are discussing a streamer named Mint and their drawing of a goblin.
They are commenting on its resemblance to the streamer.
It's cuteness and how it looks like a goblin.
Oh wait, there is another note.
Oh there is more notes.
We haven't found everything.
Oh there is more!
What's in here?
Boot?
Boot.
Boot, boot, boot.
Captain's journal.
This is the final message of Conrad Aldrichter, captain of the KMS Comet.
We are God knows where.
Yes, God really is the only one who does.
After the event happened, after witnessing the unleashing of untold powers trapped within that stone, I ran after that Lombardi woman and grabbed the stone from her.
I realized it belongs to the fatherland.
It must be protected.
That's why I have decided to lock myself inside the safe room with the stone.
Shut up Gina!
Shut up!
I will try to recreate what that damned woman did to trigger the event.
I pray it will work.
But if it doesn't...
This message is to the rescue team that finds this note.
I have written down the code for unlocking the safe door.
You will know what to do with it.
If I am dead when you find me, return the stone to the Fuhrer and tell him I gave my life protecting it.
Then here.
What was it?
Oh, the combination.
Hold on.
So it was J...
4571.
It's baby!
It's gotta be baby!
Gina, you are... Please.
Please, can you...
She's traveling through space and time.
She can't chill out even for a moment's notice.
She literally phased out of existence because she just can't chill.
Oh my god!
Girl!
J...
GM.
J was... I saw it in here.
I thought... Maybe not.
Hold on.
GM.
Oh, the O is 8.
O is 8.
And G...
is 2.
And M is 4.
It's not 1 to 1?
That's not it?
You need to do the cipher to find the right code.
Okay.
Hints.
What does it say?
Actually, I've never tried the hints.
Is it in the journal?
Where's the hints?
Where's the hints at?
Hints?
Hints!
Oh my god, 45% of fieldwork.
I'm not even halfway through!
You've got to be kidding me.
You've got to be squidding me.
Close the machine?
How do you do that?
What do you mean close it?
I just noticed it.
J...
Happy.
M.
I did it.
Spell boob.
No!
Blut.
To read it.
Read what?
Oh is it blut?
Is that what the code is?
Bald.
2026?
Oh no!
Is that a prediction?
Wait.
3666.
I found it.
This guy is freaky deaky.
Do you think this guy is still alive?
Oh my god.
I can already see what it is.
No way.
It's another Mayan drawing.
Look at his face.
He's like...
He looks so satisfied.
Machu Picchu.
All of this were stones.
So true.
He's literally feeling himself.
We love that for him.
The nose.
No.
Probably the stone, Gina.
My god.
I thought there was going to be a cutscene or something.
Oh my god.
It's so frosty in here.
I don't think that...
That's some nasty frostbite.
What does it say?
Oh his hair is bleaching in and out.
Oh the hair textures.
Oh no!
Just people.
But we need the stone.
Jump.
Be right there.
Nachos.
We got just one guy.
We can take him.
I've taken down three guys together.
Come on.
Just take it.
Come on, Indy!
What's happening?
Went to have an early X-mas dinner five hours ago and you're still screaming?
I like this game.
I would love some mac and cheese.
Noise.
We've
got it.
What's that?
What does that say?
Put it in your pocket.
Not
all the guys are like him.
Who shot?
Who shot gun?
It's probably...
Sid.
Final Fantasy 7.
Oh man.
Okay.
Who's that?
It's another baddie.
It's a guy.
Why did she look at the stone for a moment?
She looked like...
She looked like Gollum taking the ring.
I wonder if she is going to betray us.
These guys with these masks are so freaky.
Are we in trouble?
What are you going to do?
She's been kind of sus a couple of times.
Indy, when did you...
Hhenangst.
What's that?
He looks so cute in his little hat.
Hey Gantz, I have an Oshie.
Okay?
I know what devotion is.
You have no history.
No nation.
No leader.
I can't show devotion to hamburgers?
Cowabunga!
You laugh and dance.
Celebrating your own idiocy and drinking the piss you call beer.
Oh.
Push him down.
Just kick him.
Indy, just kick him and he'll fall down.
He's going to cause an avalanche.
I'm scared.
Yeah, American beer called out.
Wow.
Blue eyed person meme.
Is he crying?
The voice acting in this game is so... I feel like I'm watching an Indiana Jones movie sometimes.
Like I feel like I'm watching an actual movie.
Give me the stone.
Gina,
I hope you have a plan.
A potato!
Oh no.
Okay, now that's going to cause an avalanche.
Oh god, the granada.
Granada.
Put it in your pocket.
Put it in your bra.
Put it in your bra, Gina!
The safest place!
Gina!
Put the stone in your bra!
Get in the lifeboat.
Oh my god.
I told you!
Gina.
Gina!
I swear she does this on purpose.
Oh my gosh, what if it went down the little drain?
I was literally... You guys, I was literally just thinking, oh my gosh, what if they did a wheelhouse game there?
No way!
Oh my god!
They actually did it!
It's so great.
Oh, next.
This is so insane.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm going.
Somehow.
Hold on.
I'm going to the back of the ship.
I'll get there.
Oh, I see it.
Okay, I made it.
I'm jumping here.
Oh, what?
Just kidding.
You were not supposed to jump there.
You were supposed to jump...
Here.
Nope.
You were supposed to jump...
Okay.
I tried before.
It just didn't let me, so...
Now I'm supposed to jump.
The devs understood the assignment.
Yeah, it's so funny.
Gosh, I really... I can't believe how much I was just thinking that.
Okay, nope.
You're supposed to jump.
Oh wait, you're supposed to jump here.
And then you're supposed to jump.
Look up.
Oh, it's right there.
I was looking at that thing.
Okay.
Climb up.
And then over.
Over.
Oh my god.
Cheetah!
That was so great.
This game is a lot of looking up, huh?
It's really teaching us gamers a lesson.
Right everybody?
X!
Kill her!
Oh my god.
Oh, Gina has become just a little koala upon my back.
Don't let go.
Oh!
Yeah.
Come on little spider monkey.
Say the stone.
Read it out.
Say the stone!
Oh my god.
Fold the earth.
Oh no.
Gantz?
I love that boss is not making Gantz do his dirty work.
Come on.
Say it.
Just read it.
Ich bin unbesiegbar.
Earth splitter.
It's
Adamic.
We have to say the word in Adamic!
Utzalaim!
There it is!
And then it just rains this all over some poor town in China?
No!
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
That's so messed up!
And he don't...
I was gonna say don't like lay down and make it easier for him.
Wormhole Fulton.
I don't think we are actually in Shanghai though.
I think maybe we like... maybe there...
Maybe like we are in a restaurant or something.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Yeah, like Chinatown.
It's looking pretty bad out there.
That wooden structure.
Well, I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe.
I thought they were like doing a little...
They were gonna...
Have us believe one thing and it's actually the other thing.
Folded the earth.
It folded the earth.
Red herring.
Thank you.
I can't always remember things.
Ok, I'm trying.
Coming up.
Give me the gamer paint.
Hello?
We really are in Shanghai!
I think so.
Where is the anchor?
I guess it really doesn't matter that...
I don't know.
You are leading the way.
Oh my god.
I guess it doesn't matter that we drop the whole boat on top of everything.
Because nobody was here, hopefully.
Ok, hurry up so I can...
Oh god!
I don't think we are safe anyway.
Oh my
god.
Hello.
Are you ok?
Why do you look like that?
Oof.
Yeah, let's all just, you know, we got...
Oh it's so nice over here!
Oh!
Look!
Yeah, about that.
Um, Gina.
Picture mode?
Really?
The old town canal.
So sad.
Fish!
Yeah, it said 1937.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just gonna take that.
Oh these look good.
Indy, take these!
Indy!
Indy, there is food all over the place!
Indy, a feast!
Who's that?
What are you?
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
I guess I could have gunned him down, yeah.
Yeah, I could have gunned him down.
He was just standing there.
I didn't know what to do.
Gosh.
It's a Raiders reference.
Yeah, and then I messed it up.
Sorry.
Oh we got a map.
What am I looking at?
What?
That?
You can fly, you can fly, you can fly, you can fly.
Nice.
I'd love to continue watching but it's 6AM here.
No worries!
Go to sleep!
I wanted to get to some place a little bit more peaceful.
Before I stopped...
I guess I could stop around.
Let me see when it saves next.
I'll call it.
I could still go, but you know.
I also wanted to play the Astro Bot DLC tomorrow.
After I did the VR chat.
So...
Where?
Chino!
Chino, use your words!
Thanks for having fun with us today, Minto.
Thank you!
In fact, Germany was still a supplier and trader of China at this point.
It was an elite unit of Chinese soldiers.
Oh, that used German equipment.
I didn't know that.
We can go...
Oh, it sounds so scary.
Let's jump over here.
I don't like the sound of the sirens and stuff.
It scares me.
So scary.
I'm late.
Did I miss anything?
No!
Whoopsie!
I didn't mean to jump up like that!
Can I go up?
Gamers, look up!
Where is the gamer paint?
Gamer paint, where are you?
Looks for peace.
Finds the preludes of war.
No!
No, I need to go pet Paz!
Paz is my angel of peace, except she means war all the time.
Jump across.
Can I actually jump this?
Ok, here we go.
Oh!
I just was bad the first time.
Ok, girl.
No hands.
Barely makes it.
I know, right?
I'm sorry.
I know I keep saying, I'm gonna stop, I'm gonna stop, but I can't.
Physically, I'm just so intrigued and having so much fun with this game.
Is this how Uncharted is like?
Yes?
This area is quick?
Ok, then we'll go through it.
Get to the other side!
Staring at the wall.
I wanna play Uncharted.
Until you get to the last game?
Oh no!
This guy has...
World's thickest brain.
World's thickest skull.
Oh, the smoke.
Indy!
The smoke, Indy!
More straight combat than this, but the exploration platforming is similar.
As is the storytelling.
Oh, ok.
It's not like the combat that I'm super enjoying.
It's really, you know, I mean, it's fine, but...
You know, I'm just really enjoying the overarching story of this in general.
And also just, you know, it's really fun that we've...
That we've gone to so many locations now.
There she goes.
Oh, whoops.
And that's a 300k, Minky!
Thank you!
Oh my god.
We almost didn't make that, I feel.
It's a surprisingly worldly game.
Yeah!
Are you ok?
Oh, sorry.
It's probably fine.
It's working!
I was
getting ragdolled everywhere.
To be fair, planes are pretty much hollow back there.
Yeah, that's fair.
Yes, that's true.
I remember learning that from the boat.
They were much more lightweight.
No!
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh, I'm hitting them.
Don't worry!
Yeah, it was totally them.
It was totally them.
They got us.
Oh no!
They got us!
Oh my gosh.
Metal gear.
Oh gosh.
Driving with Eva scene.
Oh my gosh.
I'm trying!
I'm
going in.
Oh god, our plane!
Please!
I can't see through the smoke!
Need more bullets!
It's ok, we don't need the tail.
I just blasted it off so I can see better.
Obviously.
Reload while we are in here.
Strategic reloading.
Lounging!
No way!
Guys, if we get hit one more time, we are done.
Is there anyone else?
Oh my god.
Where?
Oh my god, I can't...
Exit turret!
Oh, we are actually getting out?
Oh my god.
Ok, we start from here.
That's fine.
Maybe that's our new plane though.
I was so close!
Ready?
Oh, once it goes back up...
Oh my god.
Ok, ok.
Oh, I have to be fast!
Ok, ok, ok.
Oh my god, I have to be super fast.
Too slow!
Too slow, beetle!
Don't crash!
Indeed.
No way.
This is so...
Oh my god!
Die!
My...
The only words I've been able to understand this whole game.
Oh my god.
What if I didn't grab her hand?
That would have been wild, huh?
Yay!
Into the fire!
Oh, I see your hat.
Where is it?
Deanna
Jones didn't know how to fly a plane.
Oh yeah, fly?
Yes.
Land?
No.
You look so...
I don't know how this rock would bring us halfway across the world.
The only thing I know is... My man is stunned.
No one can ever use those stones again.
Chill.
What's your theory, professor?
Think about it.
Nazis use them, they end up on the top of a mountain.
We use them and we end up dodging bullets and bombs in a war zone.
See what happens when mortals mess with this kind of power.
Doesn't end well.
Look, I can...
What is...Miss Gollum?
I can't with her.
I'm not going anywhere.
We found your sister.
Your job is done, Gina.
I'm precious.
That was so sus.
Where are the other stones?
Well, the nearest site on the great circle would be Sukhothai.
Deep inside the jungles of Siam.
Sukhothai-dees!
Not a chance.
None of the relics in the Vatican treasure chamber came from Sukhothai.
It's gotta be there.
She beat me to it.
What are we waiting for?
You are mean though.
I knew somebody would say it.
Excuse me?
Maybe he doesn't know how to fly it.
Oh my gosh.
It's like we are watching a never ending Indiana Jones movie.
It's so great.
It's my dream come true.
Truly.
Let's take the watch along.
He's back to being open shirted.
I'm glad.
I hope you guys have been enjoying it too.
Hopefully I don't make it too motion sick inducing.
With me looking all over the place like...
I hope you guys are enjoying it too though.
He needs a new shirt.
No, I paid for this DLC.
I paid for his ripped open shirt.
Some hats though.
What is that?
A jerky?
A friendly cat with a feeble meow.
Oh my god.
Little baby.
So fluffy.
I literally decided to play this game because of you.
Good.
So fun.
There's a lot of stuff that I'll miss too.
And I've already missed.
Enjoy it.
Is he going to say room?
Yeah.
Actually, just get us room.
Oh my god.
I miss my cat.
The cat is cute.
Okay guys.
Wait, is the cat still there?
Sad.
So sad.
Okay, I think I should actually call it here.
I need to finish my dinner.
I feel like...
I feel like even though this game is so long...
I feel like I could've like...
What's the word?
Played it all in one time.
Start to end.
I could keep going the whole way.
But this is so fun.
I feel like I could've marathoned the whole game.
It's one of those games.
Yeah, it is.
Having so much fun with it.
And it's like, you know, it's got brainy bits with like puzzles and sneaky bits with some guys.
And the action is not bad.
It's just like beat up some guys.
It's like just the right amount for me, I feel.
Thank you for the long stream.
Those last few sections were so intense.
Pet Paws for us.
Oh my gosh, Paws was so sweet this morning.
She's been getting like more and more like...
Sleeping in bed with me and just being a sweet...
All around sweety girl.
And this morning, she...
She doesn't... She only usually lays in bed with me at night.
But this morning, she...
After causing much mischief trying to climb up my blinds...
She decided to lay in bed with me.
And then she loves like laying on my leg.
And I got... I sat up and she laid like on my leg and stretched out.
And like let me pet her.
She's also kind of like ADHD where like if I pet her at all, she'll wanna lick.
And like if she's licking, she does not wanna be pet.
That's like her licking time.
She gets really upset if I pet her when she's licking.
So, she's just been so...
This morning, she let me...
She was like purring and stretched and happy in bed with me.
And I was so happy.
And Butaro's doing well too.
He's been recovering really well from his surgery.
And I feel like he's kind of returned back to normal like...
He's been going through like these weird episodes before the surgery where like...
He has like this...
How do I say?
Like he purrs, but it's not a good purr.
It's like trying to comfort himself.
Like it's like he's in pain.
And he's like very... He was very stressed.
And I felt really bad for him.
And he was like not relaxing at all.
And he was in the donut, so he was already so stressed.
And...
Thank you!
Thanks for hitting my heart!
Thank you, thank you!
Still on medicine or no?
Oh yeah, he's still on medicine.
But...
I've been giving him less and less.
Because he hasn't really been needing it.
But lately he's just been very calm and happy.
And I've been very thankful about that.
So I'm wondering if maybe he's...
His leg is starting to feel better.
I mean I'm sure the meds are helping too.
But maybe because he feels that there's no giant lump on his leg anymore.
That probably is really painful.
He's probably feeling...
Much more comfortable, I'd hope.
Thanks for the marathon, Minto!
A lot of cool moments in this game.
And nice callbacks to the films.
Also...
Liquid fist fight vibes on top of the plane earlier.
Except I won!
Yeah...
I think so, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hot dog!
Thanks once again for the concert.
Suffice to say, seeing you and Doki and Dobi all on stage together was really special for me.
Really thanking my lucky stars I got the chance to see you perform twice!
What a crazy year it's been.
Thank you!
I started watching your...
Wait, I watched the start of your stream from one airport and I'm watching the end from another.
Hope you had a safe flight next, see?
Hope it was a good flight at least.
Minky.
Dash me.
So, is that it for the stream?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm gonna head out now.
So...
Oh!
P.S.
It was a pleasure getting to meet a bunch of wisps and goons and connect with a few faces to names in the chat.
For someone who was never into idol stuff before getting into Vtubers, it was so cool to experience some of the culture.
Can't wait for the next time.
Yeah!
It's so fun!
You really, really, really...
You'll really get to understand it once you're there in the moment and get to see it with everyone.
Yeah, thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
Bye Mito, see you later.
Bye bye!
9 hour stream hot dog.
Yeah, I wanna do some longer streams before I go to Japan.
Like I said, I'm only in Japan for like a week and a half, so...
It's not super duper long.
I was planning on having some videos I upload while I'm gone, but I don't think I'm gonna have time to record them.
So...
Instead I'm planning on having like a...
Maybe like a Mito karaoke marathon that just plays 24 hours.
I don't think I have that much karaoke.
But...
Not the karaoke streams, I mean.
Maybe just something...
So if you're just like, oh I need something to put on...
You can put it on.
I don't know, Mito radio.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
I can...
I can do that.
I'm getting a new...
I'm getting a new computer soon, basically.
So...
I can...
Let this one run into the dust.
No, I'm just kidding.
But...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Set up Mito TV.
What do you mean, like before?
24 hour Mito karaoke.
Yeah, so if you're ever like, I need...
I want something to listen to.
You can check it...
You can watch.
And you don't have to watch.
It's just there in the background.
It's no biggie.
PC specs reveal.
I haven't...
Oh wait, no.
I've thought about just everything, actually.
Still waiting on things in the mail.
Where's my phone?
But...
I was gonna wait initially for...
I know everybody told me to wait for the new graphics card.
I know everybody told me to wait.
But...
I was like...
I got a pretty good deal on it.
Because of Black Friday.
And...
I also...
Oh my gosh, I also got a new phone.
For streaming.
The phone I'm using...
Is like...
I got it from my friend.
They...
For a hundred dollars.
It's an iPhone that has like...
The most...
It was like the first iPhone to have the...
There's like a special thing you need on an iPhone.
For Vtubing.
And it's the first phone...
That has...
The...
The thing that you need.
So it's kind of outdated.
And I was talking to Cecilia and she was just like...
Oh yeah, you probably want to upgrade that when you can.
Because...
The...
The newer phone will give you better movement.
So I was like...
Really?
Yeah, so...
I have...
I didn't get like a brand new iPhone or anything like that.
Because I don't need that.
But I got...
Like a...
I got a new iPhone.
For not too much.
I tried to like really be like...
Okay.
Getting a good setup.
CC?
No, Cecilia.
Wait.
Celia!
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
My brain is mush.
Celia!
Not Cecilia.
Sorry.
I have never talked to Cecilia.
I've never talked...
I'm sure she's a wonderful gal.
I've never talked to her before.
9 hours coming on strong.
Yeah, sorry, sorry.
But yeah, so...
Anyway.
Celia as in...
Yes, as in my papa.
Yes, Celia.
My rigger, yes.
The person that did my rigging.
The person that helps me move.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
I mix up similar names sometimes too.
I'm sorry, Celia!
If you're listening, you're probably not.
But it's okay.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Yeah.
But yeah, maybe I'll look a little bit better then.
Next year.
When everything comes in.
When everything comes in and I get everything set up.
I won't be able to set up my computer as soon as I get back.
It'll take me probably a minute to do that.
But I'll take a day and put it all together.
Or something.
Take it to someone to put it together for me.
I haven't decided.
Might be too jet lagged.
Actually, I have some stuff happening right when I get back.
But it's exciting stuff.
It's very cool stuff.
So...
Literally like two days or the day after I get back.
I have an exciting thing!
Yeah!
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Busy, busy.
Yep.
It's good though to be...
Busy.
It's good though to be busy.
Okay.
Alright guys.
Thank you all.
Sorry for a long, long stream.
If you're like, I can't watch all of this.
Well, I'll be gone for a week and a half.
So...
If you wanna catch up to anything.
That'll be your time to do so.
Otsu...
Mito!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
And...
Oh gosh, it's already midnight.
When I see you next, I'll see you!
Otsu Mito!
Sorry, I accidentally pushed a button.
Otsu...
Otsu Mito!
I just got here.